So auf gehts pünktlich um neun, neun Uhr eins
So mal warten bis Twitch mitbekommen hat, dass der Stream online ist
Ja hat's anscheinend, sind 15 Leute da
Wobei wahrscheinlich, Leute wahrscheinlich habt ihr noch irgendeinen Tab offen gehabt oder so
Weil man erkennt's meistens relativ gut wenn Twitch mitbekommen hat, dass der Stream on ist
Moin
Ranun
Jetzt, jetzt hat's, jetzt hat's Twitch mitbekommen
Ja, dachte ich mir, jetzt hat's, jetzt hat's Twitch mitbekommen
Und nachdem heute wieder Sonntag ist, Leute, hab ich irgendwas wichtiges die Woche verpasst
Die Apple Präsentation hab ich verpasst
Da hab ich mir nichts zu angeguckt, großartig, das einzige was ich davon gehört habe ist
Dass es jetzt irgendwie ein neues iPhone gibt für 1400 Euro
Und irgendwie eine neue Apple Watch, die auch Ultrafigur kostet und größer ist und ein anderes Armband hat
Ich glaub das war das einzige was ich mitbekommen habe
Ach ja und das jetzt, weil ich überleg gerade, was war denn das
Dass du jetzt irgendwie oben im iPhone neue Dinge anzeigen kannst oder so
Ansonsten hab ich nichts mitbekommen und ich fürchte fast das war's wahrscheinlich
Aber gucken wir uns nachher nochmal ein Video an, was da wirklich, was da wirklich gewesen ist
War sonst die Woche noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein und selbst, ich guck ja morgens ja immer bei Heise und Golem so ein bisschen durch
Selbst auf News Seiten war nicht wirklich was Spannendes
Also irgendwie ist alles sehr, nicht viel gewesen
Ein Ding ist gestorben diese Woche, aber das hat mich jetzt nicht so wirklich großartig interessiert
Also aus technischer Sicht oder sagen wir mal zumindest aus IT Sicht ist die Woche nicht viel passiert
Oder sehe ich das falsch? Wir gucken mal kurz in die GitHub Trends
Einfach mal schauen was die Woche, neues Home Assistant Release, das stimmt
Da bin ich auch wirklich, das hab ich ja gestern gezeigt, da bin ich auch gespannt drauf
Wie sie ihren Bluetooth-Proxys machen, aber ansonsten ist es jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig
Bahnbrechender ich sage mit, oh ja, riesen Highlight
Ich mein es ist gut, dass sie das machen und dass das so lange supportet ist
Und vor allem, dass die seit Jahren schon daran arbeiten
Aber das Release an sich ist halt ein ganz normales Release
So, was trendet denn diese Woche?
Stable Diffusion WebUI gibt es jetzt in WebUI für, okay
Lightning Fast Powerful Code Editor Written in Rust
Och please, nicht noch mehr Code Editors und nicht noch mehr Blazingly Fast Written in Rust
Das hat der Welt natürlich gefehlt, noch ein Editor
Ich sag jetzt gar nichts über die Qualität, ich hab es nicht ausprobiert
Ich hab auch nicht vor es auszuprobieren
Die E-Mail wurde beerdigt, wirklich? Das finde ich witzig, da kann ich euch was zu erzählen
Ist das, ist das, ist das RIP jetzt oder was?
Ach ja, tatsächlich, guck mal
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, es gab ja zwei, es gab ja zwei verschiedene Sachen
Es gab die E-Mail, wie soll man das ausspielen? Es gab irgendwie einen Postbrief oder sowas
Wie hieß die Konkurrenz von D-Mail, irgendwie Postbrief oder?
Es gab noch so eine Konkurrenz, ich weiß nicht wie es darum steht
E-Postbrief, genau, den gibt es bestimmt immer noch
Ein ehemaliger Kollege von mir, der hat für D-Mail gearbeitet
Das ist schon bestimmt, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre her gewesen oder so
Das hat nie wirklich Fahrt aufgenommen, das Ding
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool
China-Chinesen-Zeug, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll
Das beste, das beste Github-Repo ist immer noch
Anime Girls Holding Programming Books
Hat nicht umsonst 14.600 Sterne
Also wer schon immer mal sehen wollte, wie irgendwelche Anime Girls ein.NET Buch halten
Kann sich das dann ja angucken
Ich weiß nicht, warum es sowas überhaupt gibt
Aber gibt es
Lata kriegt viele Sterne
Poetry kriegt viele Sterne
C++-Krempel kriegt viele Sterne
China-Chinesen-Zeug
Sag mal, nochmal ein Editor, sehe ich das richtig?
Wir haben diese Woche zwei Rust Text-Editors im Trending
Wer soll diesen Kram eigentlich alles benutzen?
Ach, das ist Vim in Rust
Gut, das Gute an Vim ist halt, dass es Vim ist
Weil andere Editors, die in Vim-Modus eingebaut haben, gibt es ja zuhauf
Das ist ja auch sehr gut aussprechbar
GIFB-KAN
Gut, so heißen ganz viele Maschinen-Learning-Dinger
Moin, Phipps
Also, diese Woche ist auch nichts Spannendes dabei
Hopp, nix
Nix
Dann müssen wir mal das Wichtigste gucken
Was macht Battlefield 2042 nach Season 2-Release?
Geht eigentlich noch
Ist nicht ganz so weit unten wie noch davor
Zwischenzeitlich hat es immer gar keiner mehr gespielt, aber
Immerhin, immerhin, immerhin
Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie lang
Mal gucken, wie lang es 10.000 Spiele hat
Minipeak, ja
Leute, ich hab die Season 2 übrigens immer noch nicht installiert
Wenn ich die spielen möchte, dann müsste ich das jetzt mal machen, weil ansonsten ist wieder keiner da
Hast du One Piece geguckt?
Naja, ab und zu mal ein paar Folgen, aber ich bin sicherlich nicht der Hardcore-One Piece-Fan
Ich bin auch allgemein nicht irgendwie der riesen Anime-Fan und Gucker
Also, ich hab nicht viele Sachen geguckt bisher
Das letzte, was ich geguckt habe, ist
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es hieß
Jopless
Jopless Reincarnation, glaub ich, hieß das
Das hat mich schon in der ersten Folge äußerst verstört
Ich dachte mir, da kommt jetzt irgendwie so 08.15
Fantasy
Welt und
Standard-Gramm und, naja
Dann kam Booba
Bist du mit dem 4 zufrieden? Bis jetzt schon, ja
Bis jetzt, bis jetzt ist alles gut, aber
Muss sagen, ich hab das Ding jetzt ja auch erst
Ich glaub, zwei Wochen oder so
Zwei, maximal drei Wochen
Zwei Wochen, glaub ich, hab ich den jetzt
Ja, wobei
Es gibt jetzt so die ersten Sachen, die mir auffallen
Die
Naja, wo ich mir gedacht hab, das könnte man schon ein bisschen schöner machen
Zum Beispiel wäre es cool, wenn das Display ein HDMI-Port hätte
Input
Aber das ist halt bei den meisten Displays nicht so
Ja, HDMI-Input wäre richtig POG, oder?
Da könnte man dort anschließen, was man will und könnte auf dem Display im Auto was gucken
Es gibt zwar Alternativen zu, ja, man kann ja theoretisch
Irgendso eine Android-Box nehmen, hat fast kein Auto
Also, der Honda E hat das
Übrigens, ich hab ein richtig cooles Projekt gestern auf GitHub gefunden
Ich hoffe, das wird sich gut entwickeln
Weil dann wäre das wirklich mega nice
Für alle Leute, die Autos haben mit CarPlay bzw. Android Auto
Warte mal, GitHub
Wie ist das Ding?
Android Auto Server oder so ähnlich?
Das da
Richtig geiles Projekt
Die Sache ist halt die noch ziemlich unstable
Die Typen hier
Oder eher, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist auch nur einer
Die haben das Android-Auto-Protokoll nachgebaut
Allerdings nicht etwa die Auto-Seite nachgebaut
Sondern die kleinen Seiten nachgebaut
Also, du kannst damit quasi mit einem
Android-Auto-fähigen Infotainment-System kommunizieren
Also, du kannst damit quasi mit deinem Android-Auto-fähigen Display
In deinem Auto kommunizieren
Und kannst theoretisch beliebige Video-Quellen und Sachen drauf abspielen
So
Ich mein, es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man sowas implementieren kann
Entweder, man nimmt ein Android und routet das
Und schaltet dort halt Sachen frei, wie zum Beispiel, dass man Screen-Mirrorn kann
Oder YouTube während der Fahrt verwenden
Keine Ahnung
Die coolere Variante ist natürlich das
Irgendjemand, der das Android-Auto, also die kleinen Seiten
Von Android-Auto-Reverse-ingeniert hat
Womit man dann einfach alles machen kann
Dann bräuchte man einen Raspberry Pi oder irgendeine Kisse
Aber das Problem ist, dass es noch wirklich sehr early in der Entwicklung
Zumal es zwar schon zwei Jahre alt ist, aber
Es hat auch wohl nicht so viele Entwickler
Wenn das mal wirklich in, frag mich nicht, fünf Jahren oder so
Richtig gut ist, dann ist das wirklich mega nice
Da kannst du nämlich theoretisch alles auf deinem Display abspielen
Wireless
Du könntest beispielsweise irgendeine Linux-Kiste, irgendeine Raspberry Pi im Auto anschließen
Und könntest dann sagen, ich streame da drauf dann, in keiner Ahnung, einen GNOME-Desktop
Auf mein Autodisplay
Nicht, dass man das unbedingt machen will, aber nur so von der Idee her
Also du kannst da wirklich alles machen
Das ist, glaube ich, ja, das ist, glaube ich, C++
Ist halt, ist halt Paynes-Champ, aber gut, was willst du machen
Das ist halt
Manche Leute
Müssen sich halt quälen
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, bevor ich es in Rust machen würde
Gerade bei Sachen, die nicht so Security, also, was heißt Security
Die nicht so, nicht so kritisch sind wie, dass da mal was abkackt, mal was overflowt oder sonst was
Ist halt Rust teilweise immer noch ziemlich mühselig
Dafür ist Rust die einzige Programmiersprache
Wo du in der Regel sagen kannst, wenn es kompiliert, dann macht es das, was da steht
Wo hast du das sonst, ja?
Das macht nicht zwangsläufig das, was du dir gedacht hast
Aber es macht zumindest das, was da steht
Ohne abzukacken
Wie lernt man am besten C-Sharp? Du bindest da viele Sachen ein, das steht vermutlich in keinem Buch
Das sind ja auch zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe
Wenn du C-Sharp die Sprache lernen willst, also, Sündag, Schlüsselwörter, sonst was
Dann kannst du dir Webcasts angucken oder Online-Kurse machen
Oder du kannst dir das Galileo-Openbook durchlesen, da gelten die Basics immer noch
Und das Rest ist halt einfach eine Weile benutzen und gucken, welche Libraries einem gefallen
Also ich hab so 5-6 Libraries, die ich gerne verwende
Ich verwende beispielsweise immer noch gerne jason.net
Weil ich noch nicht bisher mit dem JSON-Serializer warm geworden bin
Ich verwende gerne Flurl als HTTP-Client
Also Zeug, da muss man gucken, was einem da so am besten gefällt
Wie sieht das mit Sicherheit und so weiter im Auto aus?
Ja, das darfst du ja auch nicht
Deswegen ist es ja standardmäßig gar nicht möglich
Ups, ich will mein Auto jetzt nicht, ganze Krempel mal kurz zumachen
So, das darfst du ja auch nicht
Deswegen ist es standardmäßig in Android Auto auch nicht erlaubt
Also du kannst Android Auto standardmäßig kein YouTube übertragen
Und auch nicht während der Fahrt irgendwelche Grafik-Dinger benutzen
Das funktioniert nicht
Was du halt machen kannst, ist, wenn du ein geroutetes Android-Gerät hast
Das darauf freischalten, weil da könnt ihr nichts dagegen machen
Was übrigens tatsächlich ein riesen Vorteil, wie ich finde, ist
Von Android, klar, du kannst iPhones und so Sachen auch routen
Aber Android an sich ist die deutlich automatisierungsfreundlichere Plattform als iOS
Also unter iOS kannst du zwar auch gewisse Sachen automatisieren
Beispielsweise mit Shortcuts
Und ja, du kannst das Ding auch teilweise routen, wenn du nicht gerade den alleraktuellsten Patch hast
Das dauert ja mittlerweile teilweise ewig, bis irgendwelche Jailbreaks rauskommen
Aber die Möglichkeiten, die du hast, was Automatisierung angeht
Und ja, was Customization angeht, ist halt unter iOS einfach nicht so weit wie unter Android
Das Ökosystem rund um C-Sharp
Ich glaube, das einfachste ist, du guckst dir tatsächlich irgendwelche YouTube-Videos an
Und du guckst auf GitHub rum, was es so gibt, Projekte mit vielen Sternen
Nur etwas, was viel downgelaudet wird und bastelst halt ein bisschen rum
Und guckst halt immer mal, ob es nicht schon was gibt, wo das einer gebaut hat
Und mit der Zeit kriegt man dann so seine Lieblingslibraries raus
Ja, zum Beispiel eine Sache, was du halt wirklich hast, was mir jetzt auch wieder aufgefallen ist
Was halt mit iPhones nicht gescheit geht ist
Du kannst zwar triggern mit Shortcuts, wenn CarPlay connectet oder so
Aber du kannst mit Shortcuts immer noch nicht gescheit Anwendungen starten
Oder zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten ohne User-Interaktion Sachen machen
Das ist gewollt von Apple, verstehe ich
Sonst könnten die Leute einfach irgendeine Endlosschleife in Shortcuts machen
Und im Hintergrund laufen lassen für Ewigkeiten
Oder eben automatisch nach Uhrzeit alle 20 Sekunden triggern lassen
Das wollen die nicht, ok, verstehe ich
Aber manchmal ist es halt cool, wenn das geht
Und unter Android kannst du sowas machen
Tasker ist somit das erste, was einem da so einfällt
Aber unter Android kannst du natürlich noch viel mehr machen
Weil du kannst dir einfach einen SSH Zugang draufpappen
Und im Zweifelsfall auch echte Scripts drauf ausführen
Also automatisierungstechnisch ist Android einfach viel, viel besser
Dafür gibt es da andere Dinge, wo man sich fragt, was haben sie sich beigedacht
Aber gut, es hat alle seine Vor- und Nachteile
Meine Mutter zum Beispiel kommt mit iOS super klar
Die findet das ganz toll
Die hat ein iPhone, eine iPad
Die hat schon das zweite iPhone mittlerweile
Und das iPad, die ist damit super zufrieden
Und die hatte vorher ein Android-Test
So ein billiges
Ganz früher hatte man Amazon Kindle mit ePaper-Display
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch jemand kennt
Gab man von Amazon solche Dinge
Hätte sie das nicht gehabt, hätte sie sich wahrscheinlich nie getraut Tablets zu verwenden
Dann hatte sie ein billiges Tablet von mir, was ich mal umsonst bekommen habe
Dann hatte sie das Shield Tablet
Und irgendwie ist sie mit Android-Tablets nicht klargekommen
Oder hatte Probleme mit
Und irgendwann habe ich gesagt, weißt du was?
Ich bestelle ihr mal zu Weihnachten eine iPad
Das ist kein Air und kein Pro und kein ganz normaler iPad
Und seitdem ist sie happy mit dem iPad
Und das funktioniert für die einfach
Also es ist auch ein bisschen unterschiedliche Benutzergruppen
Mir ist es manchmal ein bisschen zu restriktiv
Wobei ich prinzipiell auch recht zufrieden mit dem iPhone bin
Einfach aus dem Grund auch, weil ich es nicht bezahlen muss
Das hat natürlich seinen Vorteil
Wenn du einfach was bekommst alle paar Jahre
Was immer aktuell ist und du es nicht bezahlen musst
Aber an sich bin ich auch recht zufrieden mit dem iPhone
Wobei ich mir an manchen Stellen tatsächlich wünschen würde
Man könnte es noch etwas besser customisieren und automatisieren
Was du zum Beispiel komplett vergessen kannst mit einem iPhone ist
Dass du, mal angenommen du willst sowas bauen wie
Es klingelt jemand an deiner Tür
Und du willst, dass dann die Kamera sich öffnet
Dass sich das Bild von der Kamera an der Tür öffnet
Das kannst du nur machen, wenn du quasi einen Kameranbieter
Und Klingelanbieter in einem hast, der eine eigene App hat
Und das dann irgendwie als iOS-Anruf verpackt oder so
Hast du einfach nur eine Klingel, die dir um drei Ecken eine MQTT-Message schickt
Oder einen Webrequest oder was auch immer
Und auf der anderen Seite hast du eine Kamera mit RTSP-Feed
Sodass du eigentlich aufeinander reagieren müsstest
Kannst du das so was mit Tasker total easy machen unter Android
Unter iOS ist das ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit
Es geht einfach nicht
Nö, habe ich noch nicht
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Apple mit dem neuen CarPlay macht
Was irgendwann in 500 Jahren mal kommt
Du hast mal bei einem Ideenwettbewerb an iPad gewonnen
Pog, was war das denn für ein Ideenwettbewerb?
Irgendwas von der Schule oder irgendwas?
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Ja, das gibt es ja anscheinend nicht mehr
Ich glaube die iPhone Minis haben sie doch, haben sie die nicht abgesägt?
Habe ich irgendwo gelesen
Ähm
Es gab ein 13-Mini, ja aber kein 14-Mini mehr
Ich glaube die gibt es nicht mehr
Tja, wir sollen mal schauen
Was uns YouTube heute so empfiehlt
Zeig mal her
Das sind meistens extreme
G-Bait-Videos mit solchen Titeln
Ach so, dass die
Jaja
Nö
Und ich denke auch, dass wahrscheinlich
Mein nächster Rechner noch SATA-Anschlüsse haben wird
Weil woran sonst soll ich denn bitteschön meine
14T-Platte anschließen?
Man könnte sie per USB an irgendeinen externen packen
Aber warum?
Ansonsten, die SSDs sind in Zukunft wahrscheinlich exklusiv in M2-Slots drinne
Es gibt ja mittlerweile Mainboards mit 4 M2-Slots und sowas
Ok, also die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind ja heute schon mal wieder ganz
Panes-Champ-ig
Oh, es gibt jetzt ein Extended-Fire-Ship
Hat einen zweiten Channel
Tatsächlich
Ich muss die Musik ein bisschen lauter machen
Nee
Die Playlist kann sie nicht entscheiden
Bei Swisscom hast du Heim-Vernetzung vorgeschlagen
Ok
Das kann ich mir jetzt nichts drunter vorstellen
Was macht die Wagen-Anzeige?
Oh, wir verwenden ja Nitter neuerdings
Weil das keine doofen Pop-Ups macht
So
Da, guckt
Ok, die Seite ist High-Speed gerade
Neues All-Time-Low stimmt nicht
Also als ich jung war, habe ich weniger gewonnen natürlich
Aber, sagen wir mal
All 15 Jahre Low
Also angefangen habe ich mal bei 108
Ja
Und Leute, ich habe festgestellt
Ich müsste, ich müsste mal echt anfangen ein bisschen
Äh
Auf welche Körper?
Ich müsste echt mal anfangen so mal ein bisschen
Neben meinem täglichen Rumgelaufe
Was ja mit dazu geführt hat, dass ich eben so viel abgenommen habe
Abgenommen habe
Ich müsste mal anfangen tatsächlich ein bisschen
So Bauchmuskel oder sowas
Irgendwie so ein bisschen was zu trainieren
Weil
Ich habe letztens
Das wird jetzt vielleicht merkwürdig
Aber ich war letztens morgens im Bad
So
Und ich wollte meine Socken anziehen
Und als ich mir die Socken angezogen habe, sind mir die Socken runtergefallen
Also bis dahin auch nichts Besonderes
Ich hatte aber kein T-Shirt und nichts an
Und dann habe ich mich
Die Socken sind halt
Ich habe da so einen Ständer, wo die Klamotten drin sind
Die Socken sind irgendwie so halb drunter gefallen
Also habe ich mich hingekniet
Und habe da drunter gegriffen
Und habe meine Socken wieder rausgeholt
So
Und habe ich festgestellt
Ich meine es ist nicht so extrem, aber man sieht es schon
Dann habe ich so runter geguckt, so einmal im Bauch
Und habe mir gedacht
Boah, man sieht ja schon, dass du ordentlich abgenommen hast
Aber das Problem ist jetzt
Dass es halt ein bisschen hängt
Das sieht man normalerweise gar nicht
Also wenn man
Selbst wenn ich kein T-Shirt habe
Im Stehen, im Laufen, so ist alles
Siehst du gar nichts davon
Aber halt im Knien mit Bauch nach unten
Dass du halt quasi
Dass die Schwerkraft dran ziehen kann
Dann hängt es schon ein bisschen
Und da habe ich mir gedacht
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen zumindest gucken
Dass das wieder
Stylischer aussieht, ja, aber
Auf irgendwelches Trainingsprogramm habe ich ja eigentlich gar keinen Bock
Da bleibe ich lieber bei meinem täglichen Rumlaufen
Und eineinhalb Stunden rumlaufen
Und weniger fettig essen
Und ich nehme noch ein bisschen ab
Reicht mir eigentlich schon
Ich meine es ist jetzt wirklich nicht super krass wie man sich da
Also ich habe das jetzt vielleicht so erzählt als hängt es bis zum Boden
Nee, das ist vielleicht keine Ahnung
Ein Zentimeter oder ein halber Zentimeter
Man sieht es halt
Dass es auf jeden Fall nicht ausgefüllt ist
Richtig
Wann war der letzte Döner?
Boah, dass der letzte Döner ist ewig her
Aber ich denke mal Döner Teller und Köfte Teller und so zählt bei dir auch
Das ist tatsächlich auch schon
Das war noch vor Corona
Das ist bestimmt drei Jahre her
Wobei das stimmt nicht
Ich glaube, ich habe mir zwischendurch mal bestellt
Aber ein Jahr ist es auf jeden Fall her
Eher zwei Jahre
Das liegt auch daran
Ich hatte doch vor ein paar Jahren mal
Das bestimmt auch schon
Das war vor Corona
Also muss irgendwie so drei Jahre her sein
Da hatte ich doch mal eine Lebensmittelvergiftung
Und ich hatte
Wie heißt das?
Moment, muss ich mal kurz gucken
Hier
Das da hatte ich, glaube
Ja
Nicht Salmonellen
Das da
Campylobacter
Die sich ansteckende Durchfalle entdecken
Und die sich ansteckende Durchfalle entdecken
Also
Richtig
Pepo
Pepo Toilets Zoom, Leute
Pepo Toilets Zoom
Ja und genau
Was hat das jetzt mit dem Döhner
ganz einfach das merkt man nicht gleich also ich hatte das ich habe ein zwei tage lang gemerkt
irgendwas stimmt nicht aber ich konnte es noch nicht so wirklich einordnen und gut irgendwann
ging es dann los mit mit kacken näher zumindest ich habe die tage vorher ein döner teller gegessen
und ein rahmschnitzel bestellt und vielleicht kennt ihr das wenn ihr mal krank wart ihr verbindet
sachen die ihr da in dieser zeit davor gemacht habt so ein bisschen mit der krankheit also sprich
ich habe keinerlei appetit mehr auf rahmschnitzel und auf döner teller weil ich bevor ich diesen
ultra dünnschiss hatte halt die tage vorher rahmschnitzel und döner teller gefuttert habe
höchstwahrscheinlich hat es mit dem döner teller überhaupt nichts zu tun gehabt sondern es kommt
vom rahmschnitzel rahmschnitzel sind wirklich prädestiniert für solche dinger sich einzufangen
ja allein schon weil er immer ganz viel sahne und und milchzeug und sowas drinne ist in der
sauce und wenn das nicht richtig gekocht nicht richtig geklagert nicht richtig gekühlt was auch
immer ist erst halt so ein kram drinne ja rahmschnitzel ist in dem fall was das angeht
hast du das eher dadurch eingefangen als durch den dünner teller aber ich habe halt beides
gegessen habe überhaupt kein bock mehr drauf hähnchen könnte auch sein aber hähnchen ist
eher so salmonellen oder sowas also zumindest das war wirklich nicht schön das war übrigens das
einzige mal dass ich eine meldepflichtige krankheit hatte also es war korona außen vor ja wo ich das
hatte ich ja noch vor korona wo ich gar nicht wusste dass die meldepflichtig ist ich habe
auf einmal post bekommen vom gesundheitsamt dass ich irgendwelche zettel ausfüllen soll
also das war das war wirklich nicht schön das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt also man hat im
bett gelegen hat einem der bauchweh getan und wenn man aufstehen wollte weil man aufs
klo musste konnte man nicht aufstehen weil alles quasi so unsichtbar was von hinten zurück ins
bett gezogen hat das war ganz ganz weird champ das will ich nicht noch mal haben so was ja
aber zurück auch mal ganz kurz zur waage also wenn ich wenn ich es geschafft habe unter 90
dann mache ich auch mal ein video zu weil ich denke das ist wirklich nicht schlecht ich habe
dann innerhalb von also ungefähr seit ja seit februar ungefähr wo ich das so richtig mache
also ich habe dann quasi wenn ich es bis ende des jahres schaffe unter 90 habe ich quasi seit
februar irgendwie 18,5 kilo abgenommen ich denke das kann sich durchaus sehen lassen und vor allem
ich habe nichts großartig an einschränkungen gemacht normalerweise heißt sie immer du musst
kalorien zählen du musst weniger essen oder du musst irgendwie nur noch gesundes zeug also das
und das und jenes das mag alles sein wenn man noch schneller abnehmen will vielleicht das mag
bestimmt auch alles sein wenn man außer an seinem essen ändern sonst nichts machen will aber bei
mir war das alles gar nicht notwendig also ich mache eigentlich nur zwei sachen ich esse die
sachen mit ein bisschen weniger fett also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise irgendwelche sagen wir ich
esse ich habe noch kartoffeln im kühlschrank stehen und so früher hätte ich die dinger klein
geschnitten und hätte sie aufgewärmt ich habe bratkartoffeln auch übrige früher hätte ich die
aufgewärmt hätte extra noch mal fett in die fange gemacht hätte irgendwie noch mal aufgehört
oder die pomfrit hätte ich quasi extra noch mal ins fett oder irgendwelche dinger so diese
übertriebenen sachen die mache ich nicht mehr aber ansonsten ich esse das gleiche zeug was ich
vorher esse und ich esse das auch auf die gleiche zubereitungsart wie ich es vorher gegessen habe das
einzige was ich mache ist so das übertriebene fett was eigentlich das essen gar nicht mal besser
macht das mache ich nicht mehr also quasi die sachen die schon frittiert sind noch mal frittieren
das mache ich nicht mehr ansonsten esse ich das gleiche essen die gleichen mengen und auf
die gleiche zubereitungsart und weise wie vorher ist eigentlich überhaupt kein unterschied außer
halt ein bisschen weniger fett naschkram und so mache ich in letzter zeit schon relativ wenig
und was ich halt noch nie gemacht habe großartig ist cola fanta und sonst was trinken da habe ich
da habe ich glück weil das ist ja auch was was viele leute auseinander gehen lässt ja ich habe
euch ja schon erzählt von meinem kollege den ich früher auf der arbeit hatte der es regelmäßig
geschafft hat die armen lehnen abzusprengen von seinem stuhl und der auch vorwärts gar nicht
mehr ins klo gehen konnte sondern nur noch seitlich und der sich tagsüber 2 2 portionen
nudeln und dreimal pizza bestellt hat und hat massig cola und so gefuttert getrunken hat also die cola
geschichte fanta geschichten da habe ich noch nie gemacht das kann ich dementsprechend auch nicht
weglassen aber wie gesagt bisschen weniger fett und süß kam eh schon recht wenig so das einzige
was ich eigentlich wirklich mache wie gesagt das essen und so ich kann das nicht ich habe da schon
ein paar mal probiert immer mal wieder dass ich gesagt habe du ist jetzt mal ein bisschen weniger
das klappt dann auch zwei drei wochen lang wenn überhaupt aber ich das geht nicht leute ich muss
fressen ich muss das geht nicht ich muss mein zeug wegfutter ich muss voll sein nach dem essen
das funktioniert nicht anders sonst halte ich das nicht aus zumindest das hat nie funktioniert
paar wochen oder so ging das immer aber da sitzt du halt abends da vorm rechnen hast hunger und so
das ist kacke gestern habe ich beispielsweise vom pizza hut eine barbecue pizza gefressen
das ist sicherlich nicht wenig fett ich aber ab und zu kann man das mal machen so also das
einzige was ich wirklich mache ich bewege mich halt einfach so blöd es klingt das einzige was ich
mache ist tatsächlich ich bewege mich mehr das ist mehr oder weniger alles ich glaube dass mit
dem mit dem mit dem bisschen weniger fett essen ist auch nicht unwichtig aber fast zu vernachlässigen
ich bewege mich einfach bewege mich jeden tag sonntags also heute heute vielleicht nicht sonntags
ist manchmal der tag wo ich mich tatsächlich außer zum klo und zum rechner zurück oder so nicht viel
bewege aber ansonsten jeden tag jeden tag eineinhalb bis zwei stunden und ich sage euch mal ehrlich ich
habe das ja schon die letzten jahre über angefangen seitdem ich mal so längere zeit zu
probleme hatte was was was war nicht wirklich rückenschmerzen eigentlich war es eigentlich
war es wenn ich es genau wissen wollte eigentlich hatte ich schmerzen im hinteren allerdings nicht
so an diesen stellen dort wo die nerven lang laufen weil ich mich so wenig bewegt haben so
viel gesessen habe und das das lief dann darauf raus dass aber das schon ein paar jahre her da
da habe ich angefangen einfach ein bisschen mehr zu laufen dass wenn du aufgetreten bist dass es
wirklich gezogen hat so vom vom oberschenkel muskel hinten durch den poppers in rücken rein
rein vom auftreten her so und das war richtig kacke und da habe ich dass ich muss mir so ein
bisschen mehr bewegen und seit februar mache ich jetzt einfach konsequent ja da habe ich so ab
und zu mal gemacht beziehungsweise nur alle paar tage mal eine ordentliche runde und so und seit
februar mache ich einfach wirklich konsequent jeden tag sonntag manchmal vielleicht bisschen weniger
aber ansonsten jeden tag eineinhalb zwei stunden rumlaufen fertig sonst mache ich nix also ich
laufe relativ schnell rum für meine verhältnisse ja also schon so dass ich dass ich schwitzen komme
aber ansonsten mache ich nix eineinhalb bis zwei stunden hängt auch immer ein bisschen von der
strecke ab auch eines der gründe gewesen übrigens für das elektroauto weil ich laufe ganz gerne da
wo es ein bisschen bisschen hügelig ist und mein agil also ich habe eine stelle also ich habe eine
strecke die laufe ich gerne und da musst du 24 prozent steigung hoch nur kurz nur so ein paar
hundert meter und da hat mein agila probleme gehabt mit der hat es zwar geschafft aber wohlgefühle
hat er sich nicht bei und mein fiat düst die 24 prozent hoch das juckt den überhaupt nicht
ja das ist tatsächlich ein großes zeit commit das ist richtig aber also das war ja auch die sache
warum ich mich früher so gut wie nie bewegt hat ja ich habe mir gedacht ok der arbeit vom rechner
sitzen dann youtube vom rechner sitzen streaming vielleicht vom rechner sitzen die sache ist
plus die man muss es man muss sich keine eineinhalb zwei stunden am tag irgendwie bewegen oder oder
gar sport machen oder sowas in der richtung aber viertel stunde also die ersten 15 minuten sind
schon mal deutlich besser als gar nichts zu machen ich weiß nicht wie man das nennt aber
dass das flach dann flach dann ab also ich denke so als jemand der das natürlich nicht studiert
hat eigentlich keine ahnung von aber ich denke mal dass das verhält sich das verhält sich ungefähr
so also wenn du wenn du anfängst dich zu bewegen die ersten paar minuten sind halt richtig richtig
krass was du für auswirkungen hast dadurch du wirst instant merken dir tut weniger der rücken weh
und hast weniger probleme kreislaut alles und ich denke mal danach wird das halt so ein bisschen
bisschen abflachen so die positiven effekte versus die zeit die du da rein stecken muss also ich
denke wenn du die chance hast einfach eine halbe stunde am tag wirklich mal stramm zu laufen dann
bringt das schon enorm viel versus gar nichts machen genau sage ich jetzt sage ich jetzt einfach
mal ohne als ohne dass davon wirklich ahnung hätte aber es klingt logisch für mich für mich und
deswegen das bringt das bringt schon genau und dazu kommt dass du relativ schnell merkst dass es
was bringt und dann willst du das eigentlich auch nicht mehr nicht machen weil dann hast du die
auswahl zwischen die tut der rücken weh oder der pop ist weh oder dein sonst war es weh und sonst
wie beim rücken und du hast kopfschmerzen versus du wächst dich einfach eine halbe stunde am tag und
du hast es nicht und dann wirst du sagen ja gut dann mache ich lieber das anstatt das andere und
die meisten leute schaffen das ja auch halbwegs sinnvoll halbe stunde am besten halbe stunde
halbe stunde vormittag halbe stunde nachmittag wie immer das kann man halbwegs ganz gut einplanen
ja zum beispiel kannst du sagen ok ich fahre nicht mit der u-bahn zum bahnhof sondern ich laufe zum
bahnhof oder sowas in der richtung gibt es möglichkeiten wie man das einbauen kann ich
denke mal zweimal eine halbe stunde am tag das kriegt jeder irgendwie halbwegs einkalkuliert
im tag und es bringt halt auch wirklich mal wirklich was bei mir ist es natürlich länger
wenn ich eineinhalb zwei stunden allein schon unterwegs bin am laufen dann brauche ich ja
auch noch mal sagen wir so viertel stunde 20 je nachdem wo ich hinfahre sagen wir mal 25 bis
30 minuten da sagen wir 20 minuten 20 minuten hin 20 minuten zurück ich laufe selten bei mir
direkt vor der tür also bin ich quasi zweieinhalb stunden sagen wir mal unterwegs da dafür jeden
tag aber muss halt sagen seitdem ich das mache ist halt sind jetzt halt 16 kilo weg kann man sich
nicht 17 sogar kann man sich halt nicht beschweren gibt auch eine gute gute doko von art über das
thema ja das ist tatsächlich das einzige was ich mache wie gesagt ich bewege mich mehr fertig
ach ja und es hat natürlich noch weitere weitere vielleicht soll ich noch weitere positive positive
nebeneffekte psyche weiß jetzt nicht vielleicht vielleicht war das so schleichend dass ich
nicht gemerkt habe dass ich besser drauf bin oder so keine ahnung kann das kann ich jetzt
bei mir weder bestätigen noch abstreiten dass es dass es irgendwie da was ausgemacht aber wie
gesagt wenn ist natürlich insgesamt auch fitter und das ist auch nicht zu unterschätzen weil
manchmal musst du halt mal kurz irgendwo hinlaufen ja sei es dass du in frankfurt bist und was weiß
ich vom neuen ausweis abholen bis was weiß ich du musst du willst wahrscheinlich auf die zeil
irgendwas holen irgendwie sonst wie oder treppen laufen oder sonst wie also sprich manchmal kommst
du halt nicht drum herum und ich weiß beispielsweise von meinem einen arbeitskollege oder ehemaligen
arbeitskollege der hatte probleme vom hauptbahnhof ins büro zu laufen und wir sind wirklich nicht so
weit weg vom hauptbahnhof also frankfurt die strecke ist ich kann euch grob die strecke
die strecke zeigen frankfurt hauptbahnhof also von da zum willi brandplatz zu fuß neun minuten ja
ungefähr die strecke ungefähr die strecke hier musste musste man laufen um ins büro zu kommen
früher und der war fertig danach der war wirklich fertig also er hat der hat geschwitzt und und
geschnauft als ist er gerade irgendwie er hat den feldberg alleine hochgelaufen so in einer halben
stunde der war fertig und wenn du kommst dann manchmal nicht drum herum ich mein so krass schlimm
war es bei mir natürlich nie ja aber trotzdem mittlerweile ist es so wenn ich irgendwie mal
ein paar strecken laufen muss juckt mich das überhaupt nicht mehr ich kann das alles zackig laufen ich also was
weiß ich letztens hier beispielsweise mal vom willi brandplatz auf die zeil hochgelaufen nicht nicht
nicht auf die stimmte stimmt überhaupt nicht nicht auf die zeil hier oben war ich beim arzt irgendwo irgendwo hier
die waren das nicht irgendwo hier ja da bin ich halt hochgelaufen hier vom willi brandplatz hoch
bei einer halben stunde unterwegs hat mich absolut gar nicht geschockt und das bei bei
irgendwie 38 grad es hat halt schon seine vorteile wenn man zumindest ein bisschen
ein bisschen ein bisschen bewegungsresistenter wird ja man muss jetzt nicht so profisportler werden
aber ein bisschen zumindest dass ich ein bisschen bewegen kann und das hat natürlich weitere positive
positive nebeneffekte du hast keine kopfweh mehr du hast keine kreislaufprobleme mehr du hast keine
rückenschmerzen mehr die tut der popp ist vom sitzen nicht mehr weh du schläfst besser das auf
jeden fall das muss man wirklich sagen schläfst besser ok ok eine sache muss man muss man natürlich
auch noch erwähnen neben dem dass du dass du wie gesagt weniger kopfschmerzen hast und besser
schläfst du siehst auch besser aus danach das darf man ja auch nicht unterschätzen weil du
wirst jetzt nicht der krasse giga chat dadurch dass du eine stunde am tag rumläuft aber wenn
du paar kilo abnimmst du siehst einfach besser aus danach und ich habe mich letzten selbst mal in
einer meiner kameras hier gesehen ich habe hier am eingang überall ich habe ja ein paar ich habe
ja auf dem grundstück überwachung kameras und ansonsten wenn ich da vorbeigelaufen bin habe ich
mir immer gedacht max du warst auch schon mal besser in form und letztens bin ich da vorbeigelaufen
und hat mich so im profil da vorbeilaufen sehen und hat mir so gedacht also mittlerweile siehst du
eigentlich echt ganz gut aus und das ist natürlich tatsächlich psychologisch nicht verkehrt
transformations video wenn ich unter 90 bin wenn ich unter 90 bin dann mache ich ein video zu weil
dann habe ich mein ziel für dieses jahr erreicht das müsste müsste eigentlich schaffbar sein ich
meine ich habe es jetzt ich habe es jetzt hingekriegt in zwei wochen noch mal irgendwie 800 also 1,6 kilo
muss ich noch irgendwie hinkriegen und ich habe noch er zweieinhalb monate für zeit das müsste
müsste irgendwie hinhauen hoffe ich hast du deshalb mehr oder weniger gestreamt ich glaube meine
streaming sachen haben damit nicht nicht viel zu tun ich habe vielleicht eher an manchen tagen
gestreamt wo ich eigentlich kein bock hatte weil ich noch ein bisschen mehr energie hatte es kann
sein aber so richtig viel streaming sachen ist eh meistens im december wenn ich den ganzen monat
frei habe oder wenn irgendwelche spannenden dinger sind wo ich seit denke hier das kann man
zusammen machen ich streame relativ unregelmäßig also ich habe ja ich habe ja monate monate da war
ich 20 tage am stück online war erst letztens streaming streak da war ich irgendwie 20 tage
am stück online und dann gibt es monate da bin ich alle fünf sechs tage mal online
schwankt halt er hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon ab was ich halt sonst hier drum herum mache
nachdem ich kein hauptberuflicher content creator bin und auch nicht werden will bzw. nie werden
wollte auch muss ich halt auch nicht und wäre auch schwierig ich glaube jetzt mal ernsthaft
leute ich glaube es gibt wenig leute die hauptberuflicher content creator werden
können mit so einem content wie ich ihn auf twitch mache wenn sie nicht noch einen riesigen
englischsprachigen technik channel oder oder sowas in der richtung haben ja youtube also
rein mit technik graben kannst du auf twitch glaube ich nicht fulltime stream ich glaube
das funktioniert nicht weiß ich was ich weiß nicht was die gründen ich weiß nicht was die
größten streamer in dieser richtung sind aber immer wenn ich am streamen bin und gucke in
die kategorien rein bin ich zumindest deutsch sprach ich mit abstand der größe und ich will
jetzt mich nicht beschweren ich bin ich finde es richtig geil wie viele leute teilweise zugucken
wir haben ja wir haben ja teilweise an die 300 leute wenn wir irgendwelche sachen programmieren
oder basteln das ist natürlich auch schon enorm ja dass es überhaupt so viele leute gibt die das
hier erreicht das ist mir huge aber das ist natürlich nicht zu vergleichen mit anderen
content wo du deutlich mehr leute ansprechen könntest wenn man es kann wenn man es kann ich
behaupte mal ich könnte das wahrscheinlich nicht weil mich der andere content zu wenig interessiert
oder ich zu schlecht bin je nachdem wie man sieht zum größten teil dann auch weil ich keinen bock
drauf habe semper video ja semper video gucken auch relativ viele zu den habe ich letztes mal
gesehen wie er als er armer gestreamt hat sogar da haben irgendwie 80 leute oder so zugeguckt der
sprecher ja aber es ist krass also aber viel mehr zuschauer hat er auch nicht dass das das das
gräbst auch so in dem drehraum ich denke mal einfach auf youtube gibt es auf twitch gibt es
einfach nur beschränkte anzahl an leuten die sich solche streams angucken also insofern ist
das eigentlich enorm was was dabei leute bei mir zugucken beziehungsweise auch leute die bei semper
video oder bei anderen technik streams zugucken aber insgesamt hast du natürlich in anderen
kategorien auf twitch wenn du sowas hauptberuflich hauptberuflich machen willst bessere chancen wenn
du es denn kannst ja auf twitch gibt es jetzt war zwar nur ein teil von meinem satz aber wenn
man das so da steht es gibt vielleicht nicht nur aber es gibt auf twitch enorm viele beschränkte
allerdings muss ich sagen es gibt auf youtube prozentual gesehen mehr ich würde ok muss ich
das stimmt nicht ich glaube nee das das muss ich anders sagen ich glaube es gibt auf twitch mehr
beschränkte leute als auf youtube allerdings mit beschränkter leute die nicht mehr normal im
kopf sind gibt es auf twitch mehr ich würde sagen fast fast fast jeder twitch zuschauer ist in
irgendeiner art und weise nicht mehr normal im kopf ich meine guck mal die meisten twitch zuschauer
die wissen die die die können darauf antworten wenn du sie fragst keck weh oder null weh das
ist so eine frage die würde jeder 0815 typ auf der straße würde die ankunft sein was will
der von mir aber aber 90 prozent der twitch zuschauer könnten die eine antwort geben auf
was besser ist null weh oder keck weh und das das ist schon mal also in gewisser weise sind
wahrscheinlich ein hoher prozentzahl der twitch zuschauer nicht normal aber wenn du es mal
vergleichst mit youtube zuschauer die mögen vielleicht normal sein normaler sein im durchschnitt
was eben so den durchschnitt anbelangt wie die leute so drauf sind aber die eindeutig
schlaueren leute und nicht so blöden leute hast du auf twitch also auf youtube hast du ganz viel
wirklich massive 3 hat low iq richtig dumme leute wo ich mich frage alter wie kann man nur
so ein scheiß schreiben in den kommentaren und ich meine damit gar nicht mal die flamer die
flamer bei denen die die flamen halt für das du siehst unter youtube videos ist so viel kommentare
die die leute nicht zum beten oder zum tollen oder zum flamen oder sonst wie schreiben sondern die
die wirklich ernst meinen oder denke ich mir immer so alter wie blöd kann man eigentlich sein also ich
glaube dass ein hoher anteil der youtube zuschauer wirklich ziemlich 3 hat unterwegs ist und auf
twitch ist es umgedreht auf twitch sind die leute zum größten teil eigentlich eher fife hat
allerdings auch gestört tiktok fangen wir jetzt gar nicht mal an leute ich habe letztens tatsächlich
mal fast eine stunde tiktok videos geguckt nicht dass ich noch auf meine alten tage zum tiktok
gucker werde tiktok ist halt ok also es gibt schon durchaus lustige sachen ich muss sagen ich habe
mir zum hauptsächlich irgendwelche cute funny pet videos angeguckt dies fragt mich nicht warum
auf tiktok zumindest tiktok videos sind quasi wie beschreiben das das kann man das kann man
schwer in einem das kann man schwer in einem wort sagen tiktok content ist quasi so reines
wie sage ich das jetzt so also ein permanentes halten des zuschauers dass er jetzt nicht
abschalten soll ohne das zu sagen natürlich ja also wenn du wenn du wenn du wenn du auf wenn
du auf tiktok ein video machen willst dann muss permanent dann muss permanent irgendwas sein oder
dass es muss sie das ist schwierig zu beschreiben es muss permanent was sein was irgendwie die das
hirn des zuschauers in das video zieht ohne jetzt wirklich das ohne dass es jetzt wirklich
irgendwie die tiefgründige aussage im video ist es kann auch jemand sein der total gelangweilt redet
30 sekunden aber das muss in einer art und weise sein dass man sagen kann ja ok das ist halt das
markenzeichen von ihm und es muss halt trotzdem es muss halt trotzdem an diesem langweiligen
gerede irgendwas catchy mäßiges sein also sei es dass es irgendwie dass er da irgendwie jeden
satz irgendwie versteckten gag einbaut irgendwelche insider jokes keine andere es muss halt permanent
irgendwas sein was irgendwie so dass das hirn ans ans video so so bindet oder es muss nicht die
vordergründige aussage sein das ist ja bei tiktok videos ganz wichtig also die aus also das was in
dem video einer sagt ist nicht zwangsläufig das was die leute am video hält also die die wisst
ihr was ich meine so die vordergründige aus nicht nicht zwangsläufig das was die leute tiktok videos
weiter gucken lässt wie bin ich jetzt überhaupt drauf gekommen das nimmt dann so ausmaße an wie dass
es news videos gibt wo die leute wo es wo es wo news wo news erzählt werden und im vordergrund
dennst dennst irgendein sexy girl die news dass du eben nicht abschaltest es ist halt das halt so
das ist das das ist eigentlich genau das was ich meine die aussage in dem video ist eigentlich was
sie sagen ist halt die aktuellen news und was sich quasi unterbewusst am video hält ist dass
da halt irgendjemand da steht und und zu den news dennst ja das ist halt so tiktok kontern
und das passt irgendwie in die heutigen seiten einfach gut rein
take viagra die hand da ist schon für den 13 monat hypersubscription ja ich finde ich finde
meine so ungefähr das trifft tiktok videos eigentlich ganz gut so ungefähr dass das trifft
eigentlich ganz gut jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr worauf ich eigentlich wir gucken uns ein paar
wieder jetzt weiß ich gar nicht worauf ich eigentlich ursprünglich raus wollte dadurch
dass ich mit tiktok angefangen habe jetzt was zu erzählen außer dass ich letztens irgendwie
ein zwei stunden mal wieder geguckt habe sag mal was ist eigentlich aus snapchat geworden
verwendet das noch jemand außer außer hier ich habe es nie verwendet ja gut okay immer noch das
gleiche alles klar weil ich glaube snapchat ist quasi die also die user generation okay meine
persönliche vermutung folgendes ich habe angefangen genau ich habe angefangen mit icq
dann kam später später kam dann skype und jetzt kam discord und so was in der richtung und ich
glaube heute ist das so dass das weiß ich dass bestimmte generationen ihre medien so msn ja aber
habe ich die großzeit ihre medien haben ja also die boomer leute verwenden facebook zum beispiel
ja so da hängen vielleicht es aber leute in meinem alter plus älter so für 35 plus teamspeak habe
ich ganz vergessen die sind die sind bei facebook am start so und die verwenden teilweise auch noch
skype und so was in der richtung und so und irgendwann haben dann halt mal die generation
die noch für die es normal war dass es smartphones gibt also quasi die erste smartphone generation
sagen wir mal die leute die so ja so 1995 oder so in dem dreh geboren worden also sprich die
sind jetzt auch 25 oder so irgendwie schon und ich glaube das ist die snapchat generation also
die irgendwie so 15 rum waren als sie in der schule waren und es schon smartphones gab und apps gab wo
sich dann auch snapchat verbreitet hat also die die so um die 15 16 waren in der schule als
snapchat angesagt von ich glaube diese also die sich dann irgendwelche dick pics und sonst was
über snapchat geschickt haben und ich glaube diese leute ja so 95 2000 was auch immer das sind die
die heute noch auf snapchat hängen und das dürften die heute so um die um die sagen wir mal 20 25
jährigen sein also sprich nicht die ganz aktuelle generation sondern die eins davor die würde ich
persönlich jetzt so als die haupt snapchat user einschätzen zwischenzeitlich genau genau so
würde ich das auch einschätzen zwischenzeitlich gab es ja dann auch mal kick oder wie das hieß
weiß nicht ob das irgendjemand heute noch verwendet das ist das ding das ist dieser messenger der
dadurch traurige berühmtheit gelangt hat er langt hat dass die ganzen pädophilen da unterwegs sind
gab es ja gab es ja zig news zu als ein pädobärs waren auf kick ich glaube seitdem verwenden zu
recht auch niemand mehr kick und die leute werden gewarnt davor kick zu verwenden aber eine zeitlang
war kick mal tatsächlich angesagt auch als messenger keine ahnung ob das heute irgendjemand
noch benutzt aber snapchat ist glaube ich aktuell gar nicht mehr so angesagt was ist
denn was ist denn der messenger was was heute die 15 jährigen verwenden gibt es einen tiktok
messenger sowas gibt es doch bestimmt tatsächlich was gibt es doch nicht telegram ja muss sagen
whatsapp ist tatsächlich ein bisschen durch die bank weg also whatsapp verwenden omas aber
auch ganz junge leute ja ich glaube die wahrscheinlich instagram vielleicht auch noch snapchat kein
schimmer weil die leute glauben ja wirklich die leute glauben ja wir glauben ja wirklich dass
man mit snapchat videos beziehungsweise bilder nicht lesen kann mehr im nachhinein das ist
ja totaler also sobald du ein bild verschickst über einen messenger kannst du davon ausgehen
irgendjemand hat eine kopie davon also diese sache mit bild verfällt ist ja naja gut auf
der anderen seite ich bin eh immer wieder erstaunt wie technisch unfähig tatsächlich
auch noch junge leute heute sind also da kann es vielleicht so wirklich funktionieren mit
chat also das war ja der haupt wer es nicht benutzt hat ich erkläre euch das jetzt mal
warum snapchat so beliebt war snapchat war so beliebt weil du da drüber booba picks und
dick picks und s picks und nude picks und alles verschicken konntest und du konntest
diesen nachrichten quasi ein verfalls datum geben und du kannst du konntest auch blockieren
dass man die screenshotten kann und sowas wobei ich glaube das mit dem screenshotten das ging
erst später also die leute konnten quasi ihr ding verschicken über snapchat aber konnten
dafür sorgen dass das bild quasi danach weg ist was natürlich was natürlich ziemlich
bescheuert ist davon auszugehen dass es so ist aber nachdem ich immer noch den eindruck
habe dass auch sehr junge leute heutzutage wenig ahnung von technik haben könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass das sogar im überwiegenden teil der fälle funktioniert moin michael
50 billionen ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das funktioniert früher habe ich mir
gedacht okay die generation vor mir die ist klar dass sie keine ahnung von computer und
technik haben weil da gab es das ja alles nicht zumindest nicht mainstream mäßig und
ich bin immer davon ausgegangen dass alle generationen die nach mir kommen eigentlich
selbstverständlich umgang mit moderner technik beherrschen muss nicht unbedingt desktop computer
sein aber sag mal so dass sie sich nicht im internet den nächstbesten virus einfangen
weil irgendjemand sagt sie haben ein iphone gewonnen und das schlimme ist das ist heute
fast noch einfacher geworden die leute zu jebaiten im internet sich ihren kack zu installieren
wie früher meine mutter die sagt ja wenigstens immer guck mal da ist so ein komisches pop
up bei mir auf dem bildschirm da darf ich das anklicken die ist da mega vorsichtig
ja gut wahrscheinlich weil ich ihr das auch schon seit 30 jahren erzähle aber gut ne
seit 30 jahren 20 jahren erzähle ich ihr das ja auch schon und da klappt das nicht so
aber wenn ich mir angucke wie easy heute leute ihre youtube channels verlieren oder ihre
social media accounts gehackt werden in anführungen strichen das kann ja meistens nur durch irgendwelche
keylogger oder tojana geschichten die sessions übernehmen oder was auch immer kommt wo ich
mir denke wie fangt ihr euch die eigentlich alle ein ich bin davon ausgegangen dass man
so über gewisse technische kompetenzen verfügt wenn man eben geboren ist in einer zeit wo
es das alles schon gab aber ich glaube das ist fast schon was schon das der gegenteilige
effekt mittlerweile ja also als ich quasi mich damals für technik interessiert habe
für computer und sonst wie geschichten da war das halt neu aber nicht ultra neu so dass
man sich leisten konnte ich habe ja quasi so den die mainstream risierung des internets
und der computer und später smartphones und so mitbekommen damals waren die sachen halt
neu aber schon in gewisser weise erschwinglich aber halt noch nicht komplett mainstream und
sie waren halt vor allem etwas etwas komplizierter und hatten viele fallstricke noch ich sage
nur bluescreens unter winos 98 also damals musstest du dich ein wenig mit der technik
und den hintergründen beschäftigen dass du das ordentlich verwenden konntest beziehungsweise
dass du damit richtig coole sachen machen konntest ich glaube das ist das was mittlerweile
fehlt und ich sage gar nicht mal sollte es komplizierter machen oder so weil das ist
ja auch bescheuert warum sollte man es aber ich glaube das ist das was heute eben gar
nicht mehr der fall ist heute funktionieren die sachen gucken wir müsst euch mal angucken
was selbstverständlich mittlerweile funktioniert wir haben eine kamera qualität auf smartphones
die ist umlängen besser als noch vor jahren camcorder oder extra cameras oder eigene fotos
also geräte was da an sensoren drinne ist eignet sich für so viele sachen du kannst
damit von räumen aus messen bis geschwindigkeits gps bestellung du hast so viele möglichkeiten
drinne dass und es gibt auch mittlerweile so viele gute ausgereifte apps die das verwenden
dass du viele sachen einfach komplett selbstverständlich erwartest und dir gar keine gedanken mehr
machst ja wie klappt das eigentlich ich habe zum beispiel letztens zum ersten mal dieses
google hat jemand von euch schon mal dieses google maps feature verwendet wo man so durch
das durch die kamera gucken kann ich weiß gar nicht wie das heißt augmented reality
oder sowas das ist ein feature live view das da meine ich genau dass das meine ich hier
du kannst quasi dein ne das hier du kannst quasi eine route eingeben in google maps und
dich navigieren lassen und wenn du dein handy hoch klappt so dass es die kamera die straße
sieht zeigt er dir an wo du jetzt abbiegen musst quasi in 3d der overlay das über das
kamera bild eigentlich eine richtig coole funktion und das sind solche dinge muss ich
mal überlegen wie viel dort im hintergrund passieren muss und wie viel jahre entwicklung
das gekostet hat dass sowas funktioniert das mag uns vielleicht klar sein ich weiß wir
haben hier relativ viele auch programmieren sonst wie also sprich wir sind ja noch leute
die technisch ein bisschen ahnung haben ich glaube uns ist das klar was dort im hintergrund
alles an dingern geschaffen werden musste erst mal die letzten 15 jahre über und programmiert
werden musste und erfahrung gesammelt dass sowas überhaupt geht heutzutage sind das
drei zeilen code um auf die augmented reality abbiege zu greifen ja so und ich glaube heute
erwarten die leute quasi ja gut das ist halt eine neue funktion in der app und die funktioniert
ja auch ganz gut das ist in ordnung ja das ist dann halt so das wird einfach so zur kenntnis
genommen dass das halt so ist und dementsprechend wenn es dann halt mal nicht geht ist man dann
halt total aufgeschmissen weil man sich nie gedanken drüber gemacht hat warum geht das
denn so gut oder warum funktioniert das überhaupt ja dann fahren dann laufen die leute durch
den tunnel und auf einmal zeigt das ding misst an und die sagen alter mein handy ist kaputt
navigation geht nicht mehr kommt nicht auf die idee dass sie grad durch den tunnel laufen
das sind halt so dinge die wenn man bisschen die zusammenhänge verstand hat klar sind
dass das im tunnel vielleicht nicht so gut funktioniert aber leute die einfach das komplett
als gegeben hinnehmen was eben glaube ich aktuell viele machen die denken dann alter
mein handy ist kaputt drecksdinger oder wenn im tunnel auf dark mode geschaltet wird komplett
komplett magic ja ja mein gott das war jetzt ein beispiel ich das war mir klar dass jetzt
wieder irgendeiner kommt und sagt aber machs im tunnel funktioniert doch trotzdem aber
ihr wisst was ich meine ok so wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein paar videos an was haben wir
denn hier zu bieten die ace plan for now please please kein kein battlefield jetzt next battlefield
noch schlimmer fire ship ihn aber auch mal hier guck ich mega gerne die videos normalerweise
nicht im stream erstens weil die themen immer sehr im chat zu ausufernden diskussionen einladen
wo dann manche leute auch über die strenge schlagen aber ich finde ich stimme da nicht
immer komplett zu aber ich finde das immer vom vom ansatz her ganz interessant und er
hat ein video hochgeladen zu wechseln von android zu iphone hat normalerweise hat nichts
damit zu tun was zu tun was er sonst macht auf seinem channel aber ich bin mal gespannt
wie das ein technisch vielleicht jetzt nicht so man kann man nicht sagen er hat schon relativ
viel ahnung eigentlich von dem was er erzählt vielleicht einer der die sachen nicht selbst
programmiert dazu sagt es ist 100 prozent subjektive da gehe ich von aus bei so einem
video da gehe ich von aus bei so einem video da können wir uns angucken was es neue sachen
gibt bei apple kommen wir lassen uns wir lassen uns level capture beten wir lassen uns eine
wir lassen uns eine runde level capture beten und wir gucken aber wir gucken nicht das komplette
video weil das komplett das ist immer ok also erstes thema können wir uns angucken das
wird nicht passieren star citizen juckt mich auch nicht cyberpunk juckt mich auch nicht
witcher 4 da warte ich mal bis es wirklich was gibt ok schauen wir mal schauen wir mal
ich werde gern von level capture betet ja diese maps die machen mich immer fertig wenn ich
die sehe das container field mann was wo sind die hin die ordentliche maps machen können
guck mal ihr müsst euch vorstellen das muss man sich mal vorstellen 2 new battlefield
games also ich weiß ich mein man muss sagen dass die battlefield 3 maps und battlefield
4 maps jetzt jetzt vielleicht auch nicht die ausgefallensten maps hatten ja das waren
straßen aus beton oder es waren wüsten basen in der wüste oder es war basen im gebirge
oder also da ist jetzt nix dabei gewesen wurde gesagt hast alter krass noch nie gesehen aber
das waren halt ordentliche maps und nicht nur drei container nebeneinander gestellt
also wenn xqc das event gestreamt hat darf man das vielleicht ich mein es gibt tatsächlich
sogar ein hinweis für dass man es streamen darf weil mein strike ist weg ich wurde ja
gestrikt vor zwei jahren weil ich ein apple event gestreamt habe und das strike ist weg
entweder verfallen die dinger nach einer weile auf twitch oder apple hat die strikes tatsächlich
zurückgezogen weil man es jetzt darf
also auf twitch verfallen strikes eigentlich nicht naja also schauen wir uns das mal an
also es gibt jetzt ein cyberpunk anime das ding sieht ein bisschen aus wisst ihr wie
die map ein bisschen aussieht an welche bad company 2 map denkt ihr falls jemand sich
überhaupt noch dran erinnern kann hat ein bisschen war ein bisschen was von hat ein
bisschen was von attakama desert in bad company 2 mit dem schiff nur dass attakama desert
ordentliche basen und zeug hat guck hier hier mit dem schiff in der mitte aber man erkennt
es nicht so genau ah guck hier das mit dem schiff in der mitte sieht tatsächlich ein
bisschen so aus ich würde nicht wundern wenn sie sich sogar sachen geklaut hätten davon
guck hier das da dieser dieses areal auf der map das sieht tatsächlich hat tatsächlich
ein bisschen was davon geht auch ein bisschen runter von beiden seiten da ist ein kaputtes
schiff in der mitte vielleicht haben bestimmt die container copy pasted aus bad company
das bettelfeld universe hatten die bettelfeld spiele bisher überhaupt irgendwas miteinander
zu tun ne ja doch doch 2042 und bettelfeld 4 hat auf jeden fall was miteinander zu tun
weil irish dabei ist aber ich hoffe ich hoffe gar keins mehr und die lassen mal leute dran
die wirklich bock haben im bettelfeld zu entwickeln und ahnung davon ich meine nur weil da ist
den kempel mal erfunden hat von leuten die einen schon gar nicht mehr da sind sind die
mittlerweile glaube ich auch nicht besser qualifiziert als andere man hast ja gesehen die beherrschen
ja noch nicht mal ihre eigenen frostbite tools ordentlich natürlich kommt mehr content es
kommen noch zwei seasons weil sie das versprochen haben und verkauft haben
das glaube ich nicht ok in den nächsten fünf
jahren kann viel passieren aber ich glaube es einfach nicht weil ganz im ernst microsoft
müsste sich versprechen dadurch quasi mehr geld zu machen als durch die verkäufer auf
der playstation sie könnten eventuell mehr geld haben weil sich mehr leute den xbox game
pass holen sich vielleicht mehr leute in xbox holen oder was auch immer services von microsoft
also rechnen gegen rechnen kann man das mal aber ich kann mir beim besten willen nicht
vorstellen dass alles in allem unterm strich microsoft mehr geld mit einer xbox exklusivität
machen würde als durch die verkäufe und einnahmen auf der playstation die ist genau es könnte
höchsten so sein dass sie so machen wie früher das dlc ist irgendwie ein paar tage früher
auf der xbox kommen oder sowas ja gut quasi das was sie seit einer weile auf der zwischendurch
dann mal auch mit sony gemacht haben früher war das ja alles ziemlich xbox gemünzt bei
cot da kam ja auch dlc teilweise früher raus und dazwischen sage ich mal beide bei sony ja
das kann sein aber exklusiv im leben nicht
yes this comes after microsoft boss phil spencer revealed that the company is committed to
keeping cod on playstation for several more years of course sony isn't happy with this
and ceo jim ryan called the proposal inadequate he believes losing cod after almost 20 years
would have a massively negative effect on playstation gamers natürlich also states
that it would be difficult to create a franchise that could rival activision's call of duty
ich kann die maßger auch nicht mehr sehen ich finde das sowas von unpassend im originalen
mw2 hatte den munt schutz mit einem mit einem mit einem gesicht drauf auf und keine maske
das ist einfach so richtig dumm eine echte maske aufzuziehen lawyers across the uk europe
and u.s. will continue to monitor the agreement to see if the takeover will create a monopoly
call of duty warzone mobile was also teased for the first time it hints at the return
of the fan favorite verdansk map and that more details will be shared at their cod
verdansk star citizen developers have been hard at work on the project red
ok dazu wird ja nicht wirklich was sagen können weil dazu gibt es nix wahrscheinlich
weiß worauf er sich bezieht ich habe das ist es gibt nix ja mehr weiß man ja auch gar
nicht
in sofern schon bemerkenswert dass die leute heute noch neue secrets in diesem game finden
irgendwie zehn jahre oder so nach release das ist so fast ich das hat doch also fast
zehn jahre alt oder ok nicht ganz ok na na ja nicht nicht wirklich aber drei drei sieben
sieben jahre als dann fehlt auch was aber ja also es ist schon ein bisschen älter und
die leute finden sieben jahre später immer noch secrets in diesem game also nicht nicht
irgendwelche secrets wo einer was an die wand gesprayt hat oder so so nach dem motto
ihr werdet es niemals finden sondern wirklich irgendwelche versteckten quests oder irgendwelche
versteckten was heißt versteckt nee gar nicht mal versteckt im sinn dass es schwer
zu finden wäre sondern einfach npc xy reagiert tatsächlich darauf wenn du die quest vorher
abgeschlossen hast und sowas also die haben an sehr vieles gedacht in witcher 3 also sieben
jahre später so viel zeug was da immer noch entdeckt wird ist wirklich da sieht man was
da reingeflossen ist in das spiel war übrigens auch das einzige was ich wirklich gerne gespielt
habe aber das lag zum größten teil daran dass die open world gute gute kulisse für
eine ordentliche story ist und nicht so sehr die open world alleine der anreiz alleine
ist es zu spielen das ist ja das wo ein bisschen die neuen assassins creed games dran kranken
dass man eine riesen mega open world hat zum größten teil computer generiert mit milliard
den sachen zu machen aber eigentlich vollkommen umsonst so für die hohle hand so komplett
unsinnig so und deswegen habe ich das letzte also wahlhalle habe ich mir schon gar nicht
mehr gekauft auf odyssey hatte ich auch nicht wirklich ich hatte das habe ich mir gekauft
nicht großartig mehr bock die map unten gerade der hat es auch das gefühl die haben da die
haben da insel und sehen gemacht weil das ja odyssey heißt das game also keine ahnung
das war einfach zu viel das ubisoft in gestern habe ich nur eine viertel stunde oder so bei
dense gaming geguckt und dann fand ich so langweilig dass ich wieder ausgemacht habe
der
Okay, man weiß, dass man nichts weiß.
Grafikkarten, so blöd es klingt,
durch so die aktuellen Krisen auf der Welt
und dadurch, dass die Leute weniger, äh, ich weiß nicht, weniger Geld,
dadurch, dass die Strompreise so gestiegen sind,
hat es tatsächlich den Effekt, dass mittlerweile Hardware
wahrscheinlich wieder etwas erschwinglicher wird
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen besser zu bekommen ist.
Klingt vielleicht blöd, aber allein schon dadurch,
dass Mining nicht mehr attraktiv ist, sorgt das halt einfach mal dafür,
dass saumäßig viel mehr Grafikkarten eben zu erwerben sind für normale Preise.
Jetzt ist halt das Blöde, genau, dass die Leute aktuell gar kein Geld mehr haben,
sich das zu kaufen, weil sie es für anderes Zeug brauchen,
aber man würde es wenigstens wieder bekommen.
Also ich spekuliere ja drauf, dass ich mir nächstes Jahr
tatsächlich mal wieder einen neuen Rechner kaufen kann.
Mal gucken, was dann die neue Ryzen-Generation macht
und mal gucken, was dann die neue Grafikkarten-Generation macht.
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich hab jetzt seit 4 Jahren oder so...
Ihr, guckt euch das mal an. Wir runden das jetzt mal auf.
Ich hab meinen Rechner, ohne Scheiß, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
5 Jahre, 5, 5, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
5 Jahre! Und ich kann damit immer noch alles in ordentlichen Details spielen.
5 Jahre! Also jetzt mal richtig Boomer-Modus, das hätt's früher wirklich nicht gegeben.
Früher war nach 2 Jahren war das vorbei.
Nach eineinhalb, zu Zeiten, wo so Spiele rausgekommen sind wie Far Cry 1.
Da war mein Rechner irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre alt.
Und ich konnte das Ding spielen auf den lowesten Settings.
Das Einzige, was ich ein bisschen höher machen konnte, ist die Texturqualität.
Ich hatte damals eine GeForce 3 oder so, glaub ich.
GeForce 3 und CPU weiß ich gar nicht.
Atlon 1900 plus oder so vielleicht? Nee, das war später.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also Leute, das war nicht richtig spielbar damals.
Und mein Rechner war damals gut und nur eineinhalb Jahre alt.
Und heute ist mein Rechner 5 Jahre alt und ich kann alle neuen Spiele in hohen Details spielen.
Was ist denn da los? Also das ist wirklich nicht, das ist echt nicht normal.
Gut, die 1080 Ti war auch eine ordentliche Grafikkarte zur damaligen Zeit.
Das muss man sagen, die war verhältnismäßig schnell.
Gerade im Vergleich zu den Nachfolgegenerationen war die ja fast schon unrentabel schnell für Nvidia.
Man konnte quasi die nächste Grafikkartengeneration überspringen und bis zur aktuellen High-End-Grafikkarte
im Prinzip auch die darauffolgende Generation überspringen.
Also die war wahrscheinlich einfach zu gut.
Aber gut, man, da kann ich mich jetzt ja als Konsument nicht drüber beschweren.
Aber muss man sich echt mal vorstellen, 5 Jahre alter Rechner und ich spiele die neuesten Sachen immer noch auf hoch.
Und wenn ich die Sachen nicht auf hoch spiele, dann liegt das nicht daran, dass sie nicht laufen würden.
Sondern weil es mir lieber ist 100 FPS zu haben als 50.
Wahnsinn, also das 5 Jahre alter.
Und wahrscheinlich noch mindestens ein weiteres halbes Jahr bis die neue Generation rauskommt.
Das ist schon heftig.
Ich glaube dazu muss ich echt mal ein Video aufnehmen, wo ich das nochmal erzähle, dass ich die Welt nicht verstehe.
Die Prozessortechnik bewegt sich seiner Grenze zu.
Die Prozessortechnik bewegt sich vor allem auf die Grenze des Machbaren zu, wenn der Platz gleich bleibt bzw. nicht übermäßig steigen soll.
Ansonsten machst du es wie Apple und machst einfach eine CPU, die 5 mal so groß ist wie alle anderen CPUs und dann ist das Ding auch schnell.
Das ist mittlerweile auch überhaupt nicht mehr so.
Zur Xbox 360 Zeit war das vielleicht noch so.
Ganz knapp.
Da war das vielleicht noch so.
Ausgehende Xbox, also am Anfang auf jeden Fall ausgehend 360 schon gar nicht mehr.
Aber mittlerweile definitiv nicht.
Also mittlerweile hält ein PC fast länger als eine Konsole.
Passt.
Ähnlich, ähnlich lang.
Okay, lass mal kurz fertig gucken.
Ist das das Ding, was so ultra viel Strom fressen soll?
Ja, übrigens eine Sache, die ich dir vielleicht jetzt auch nochmal dazu sagen muss, dass man sich da vielleicht
so langsam an die Grenze ran bewegt, so das realistisch mögliche mit den aktuellen Voraussetzungen.
Deswegen bin ich der Meinung, nachdem sich bei den Spielen die letzten Jahre, natürlich es tut sich immer noch was,
muss ich mal angucken, was sie beispielsweise bei Unreal 5 machen.
Wobei es da halt eher die Kombination daraus ist, dass eben modernste Technologien unterstützt werden,
aber vor allem halt die Entwicklertools zur Verfügung gestellt werden, diese ordentlich benutzen zu können.
Bei Unreal hast du jetzt ja diese Sachen mit, du kannst beispielsweise komplette Umgebungen,
wie heißt das, also quasi fotografieren und dann im Spiel verwenden und so was.
Richtiger Fivehead Kram.
Das macht es natürlich einfacher in der Benutzung.
Und Grafik sieht das Ganze natürlich auch gut aus, aber das sind ja trotzdem,
sind das keine Grafiksprünge wie von Half-Life 1 zu Far Cry 1 oder sowas.
Und das war ja auch nicht viel Zeit dazwischen.
Das waren keine Ahnung, drei Jahre oder so Unterschied.
Genau und das sieht beeindruckend gut aus, aber das haben die Sachen vorher auch schon.
Also es ist nicht der große Sprung.
Deswegen bin ich der Meinung, es ist aktuell tatsächlich sehr wichtig,
nicht nur die Grafikkarte zu ziehen, so nach dem Motto, wie das Crysis quasi immer gemacht hat.
Eines der Hauptverkaufsargumente von Far Cry 1 und Crysis war,
es sieht geil aus, es sieht geiler aus als alles andere, was es zurzeit gibt.
Wobei ich ja persönlich sage, mir hat das Gameplay von Far Cry 1 tatsächlich gut gefallen.
Mir hat tatsächlich auch diese etwas verworrene Storys mit Mutanten und sonst was in Far Cry 1 ganz gut gefallen.
Und mir hat auch das Gameplay von Crysis 1 ganz gut gefallen.
Also man hat ja immer gesagt, das erste Far Cry und Crysis war eher so eine Technikdemo, aber ich fand es nicht schlecht.
Zumindest es reicht nicht mehr zu sagen, ich bin Crysis und bin der Geilste von allen in der Optik.
Ich glaube heute ist es so wichtig, wie lange nicht mehr.
Ich sage nicht wie schon immer, weil früher war das definitiv auch so.
Aber du konntest jetzt lange Zeit einfach Grafikpländer produzieren, wo Grafik halt alles war.
Das geht in der heutigen Zeit denke ich nur noch bedingt.
Das sieht, guck mal, ihr müsst euch mal manche Indie-Games angucken, wie geil die aussehen.
Einfach weil heute eben die Tools und Technik zur Verfügung steht.
Ich glaube es ist heute so wichtig, wie schon lange nicht mehr, dass ein Game einen gewissen Charakter und Identität hat.
Ich meine ernsthaft, Fortnite ist das beste Beispiel für.
PUBG hat eine realistische Grafik, naja gut, ehrlich gesagt PUBG sieht auch scheiße aus.
Sehen wir mal ehrlich, PUBG sieht scheiße aus.
PUBG hat zwar einen realistischen Grafikstil, aber es sieht schon irgendwie kacke aus.
Und vor allem läuft es kacke, ich weiß nicht ob das immer noch so ist, aber es war zumindest früher so.
Und Fortnite sieht halt alles andere als realistisch aus.
Aber du siehst halt, dass Leute, die Fortnite erstellt haben, ein bisschen Ahnung davon haben,
wie man Spiele designt, dass sie eben einen gewissen Wiedererkennung, einen gewissen Charme, einen gewissen Wiedererkennungswert haben.
Mittlerweile ist es halt so, dass dieser Comic-Fortnite-Look,
ich will nicht sagen, dass Fortnite das erste Spiel war, was das gemacht hat, bei weitem nicht.
Guckt euch mal die ganzen Blizzard Games an, die hatten auch einen recht eigenen Comic-Look immer.
Aber den man ohne Probleme von Fortnite unterscheiden kann.
Also es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, guckt euch Vogue-Grafik an und Fortnite-Grafik, alles Comic-Scheiß.
Nee, nee, also mal ganz im Ernst, wer beispielsweise Wind Waker nicht von Blizzard Games und nicht von Fortnite unterscheiden kann,
also dem spreche ich mal ab, irgendwie Augen zu haben.
Das ist zwar alles Comic-Look, oder alles so, früher hast du das Cell-Shading-Look oder Borderlands, das sieht halt einfach komplett anders aus.
Ja, das ist alles so ein bisschen Cartoon-Comic-Look, aber es sieht doch, style-technisch sind da noch Welten dazwischen.
Und vom unterschiedlichen Stil her, das erkennt man doch.
Zumindest deswegen ist es einfach wichtig, dass Spiele irgendwie Charakter und Identität brauchen.
Sieht man auch aktuell, wie heißt das hier, das glaube ich.
Das ist auch ein Game, was hauptsächlich punktet durch die Optik, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Die Leute finden die Optik einfach super.
Zum Gameplay kann ich nichts sagen, weil ich habe es weder gekauft noch gespielt, aber allein schon die Optik gefällt vielen Leuten einfach.
Es gibt viele Beispiele.
Ja, das meine ich ja, rein mit ultra-realistisch kannst du halt auch nichts mehr reißen, es gibt genug Spiele, die gut aussehen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, fertig.
Warte mal, die PS5?
Das ging bisher nicht?
Ernsthaft?
Okay.
Das ist übrigens...
Tatsächlich, anscheinend nicht.
Mal davon abgesehen, also, das ist was, was oftmals verwechselt wird.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt noch mal was zu sagen.
Nur weil eine Konsole 4K-Output unterstützt, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass die Spiele in 4K gerendert werden.
Das ist ein Trugschluss, wenn man solche Bilder hier sieht, weil dann immer da steht, irgendwie 14 Milliarden Mal mehr Pixel, das ist nicht so.
Ich glaube, ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, aber war es nicht sogar so, dass sogar die Xbox 360 4K konnte?
Als Output-Modus?
Die letzten Versionen von der Xbox 360?
Also, mit was ein Spiel intern läuft und mit was dann letztendlich das Bild upscaled an den Fernseher gesendet wird, sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Und es macht auch erstmal eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied, von der Theorie her, ob ich an den Fernseher ein 1080p Bild ausgebe oder ein 4K Bild.
Dann ist einfach nur die Frage, wer macht besseres Upscaling, weil der Fernseher hat einen 4K Panel, der kann nur 4K anzeigen.
Entweder upscale ich mein 1080p Bild auf der Konsole auf 4K und füttere den Fernseher mit 4K oder ich füttere den Fernseher mit 1080p und lasse den Fernseher das Upscalen auf 4K.
Ich würde sagen, prinzipiell dürfte das die Playstation 5 etwas besser hinkriegen als der Fernseher, muss man aber praktisch ausprobieren.
Ich denke, bei den meisten Fällen wirst du wahrscheinlich den Unterschied nicht gut sehen.
Nicht großartig sehen.
Genau, äh, stimmt, und jetzt kannst du 1440p ausgeben.
Wäre der TV nicht besser, weil die Playstation 5 schon genug zu tun hat?
Naja, in der Theorie schon praktisch gesehen ist die Einheit, die das Upscaling macht, wahrscheinlich nicht daran beteiligt, die Spiele zu rendern.
Da gibt es irgendein Hardware-Ding, wahrscheinlich integriert in der Grafikkarte, das macht ja nicht die CPU das Upscaling.
Was das Upscalen, das geht wahrscheinlich on the fly ohne irgendwelche Performance-Einbußen.
Vollwuchs, danke für den Sub.
Jetzt gucken wir erstmal fertig.
Da surfte der Controller.
Hat die Switcher ich mittlerweile in den Browser?
Nee, oder?
Ach.
Ok, da bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt.
Also ernsthaft, Bioshock 1, richtig hyper-porge, Bioshock 2 wurde nur gemacht, weil man es machen kann.
War von der Idee her ganz ok, aber...
Ich fand's jetzt nicht so toll, muss ich sagen.
Infinite war auch ok, mehr hab ich ihm nicht mehr im Kopf dazu ehrlich gesagt.
Also das Bioshock Game, was mir wirklich mit Abstand am meisten im Kopf geblieben ist, ist Bioshock 1.
Leider war der Endgegner ziemlich langweilig.
Aber ich mein Bioshock 1 sollte eigentlich ja so ziemlich eine der, ich sag nur Golfschläger,
eine der erinnerungsträchtigsten Szenen überhaupt dabei gehabt haben, oder?
Also wenn ich Golfschläger sag, jeder der Bioshock 1 gespielt hat, wird sich wahrscheinlich dran erinnern.
Ja, ich bin total zufrieden mit Bioshock 1.
Also das Bioshock 1 war echt ein ganz tolles Spiel.
Es war wirklich ein tolles Spiel, aber ich bin auch sehr zufrieden mit Bioshock 1.
Ich bin auch zufrieden mit Bioshock 1.
Es war wirklich ein tolles Spiel.
dabei
Was war denn das big announcement bitte bitte schön der jetzt jedes mal das gleich am ende
Ich bin für ripple effects
Neue multiplayer game in ridgeline games new campaign oder hat 2042 dich komplett von der serie ausgelöst. Lass uns in den kommenten wissen
1st person shooter klassich wolfenstein enemy territory gemacht von splash damage hat eine neue
Dedicated server after to my enemy territory ist doch multiplayer game gewesen wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz meine erinnerung versagt
Bethesda has spun up servers running the original six maps and ruleset
There's four dedicated servers to choose from one in each region that the game is available
Many fans have wondered why Bethesda would do something so generous for the community
Maybe there's a secondary motive or is it just good guy Bethesda
It is pretty cool that players can hop back in now and play that 2003 classic and that wraps it up for this weekend gaming
As always guys, thank you so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed and I'll catch you next level cap
Wenn wir die auswahl haben zwischen macht Bethesda das aus reiner nächstliebe oder weil sie sich dadurch geld erhoffen
Ich glaube wir können alle sagen was es ist oder
Das sind ja so haben sich ja schon in vergangener zeit als besonders so als große menschenfreunde rausgestellt immer
Er anscheinend dass sie jetzt selbst offizielle server zur verfügung stellen so habe ich das verstanden
16 auch gott erinner oh nein erinnere mich nicht da dran
Was wie sieht es eigentlich vor fallout 76 die was hatten das so aktuell für stp für spieler eigentlich so
naja
Immer mehr als bennett viel 2042
Aber das ist ja auch keine kunst
Also dafür dass es da hängen es hat so relativ viele spieler so
Was geben wir uns jetzt als nächstes darf man so next battlefield muss man nicht noch mal noch mal angucken
Ich muss mal kurz die titel anschauen was haben wir denn hier sonst noch new server
Oh nein, please das ist der kerl mit fünf kuppernets cluster daheim
Das habe ich nur aufgemacht weil ich mir gedacht habe das wird wieder
Ziemlich ziemlich pepega das ist der mit mit mit fünf mit fünf kuppernets cluster und und was auch ich
Was weiß ich noch alles daheim wo ich mich immer frage was was was macht er eigentlich
Und jetzt hat er 900 terabyte storage server warum
What should I do mit vielleicht sollte er sich das überlegen bevor er sich in 100 terabyte server kauft
Vielleicht braucht die 100 terabyte um seine fünf kuppernets cluster ordentlich verwalten zu können
Für seine ganzen logs doch das war bestimmt auch der
5 5 5 kuppernets cluster
Drei rancher os cluster was weiß ich und im prinzip hat er ja nur container gehabt um andere container zu verwalten
Ok zeig mal her
Ach moment das gesponsorte server
Ach ein sponsor server ja das ist ja noch selten moment ich muss mal kurz meinen prozess explorer aufmachen
Irgendwie ist mein rechner ausgelastet zumindest fühlt sich das so an
Ist er nicht
Ok danke müssen wir uns das wahrscheinlich auch nicht angucken
Moment das ist ein storage server ohne wechselplatten rahm was denn das
Was soll das sein es gibt wirklich welche die storage server verkaufen ohne ordentliche hotswap rahmen vorne dran
Das ist doch nix
Das ist nix
Die dinger müssen einfach so da untereinander rein fertig
Die ganzen youtuber haben alle 45 drive cases ohne ich frage mich auf was mit denen los ist
Ok das muss ich
Wait a minute
Ist es nicht der typ der gesagt hat dass er kein firefox mehr verwendet um dann zwei wochen später zu sagen er benutzt
Jetzt wieder firefox weil das war das ist ja doch oder ich verwende kein firefox mehr aber ich habe jetzt wieder firefox
20 thread ist die base clock speed of 2.2 gigahertz in ken turbo ok ich will mal weiter was macht der damit jetzt
weil aktuell ist es ja einfach nur ein sell out video und er hat ein wenigstens zwei netzteile ok er hat zumindest schon mal zwei netzteile das ist fast drin
Stuhl boah das einer das stuhlkommando verwendet hat ist glaube ich schon ein jahr her wusste ich gar nicht ich wusste gar nicht dass wir ein stuhlkommando haben ich check mal kurz ob es wirklich ein stuhlkommando ist
Stuhl boah das einer das stuhlkommando verwendet hat ist glaube ich schon ein jahr her wusste ich gar nicht ich wusste gar nicht dass wir ein stuhlkommando haben ich check mal kurz ob es überhaupt noch stimmt was da drin steht
Drehsessel, Testsieger, Armlehnen, Büro, Sessel, Bürostuhl das klingt ja fast wie ein China-Chinesen Ding auf Amazon ok zeig mal her
Ja das ist immer noch der richtige Stuhl
Korrekt
200 Kilo ja da kann ich jetzt doppelt drauf sitzen mittlerweile ok das interessiert mich jetzt relativ wenig das Ding hat nichtmal ordentliche ok vielleicht sind die Dinge Hotswap fähig weiß man nicht kann durchaus sein
Ist es Sata oder Sass ist die Frage wahrscheinlich Sata was auch vollkommen ok ist aber es sollte vielleicht einen ordentlichen HBA drauf haben
Die Frage ist ob Hotswap fähig und schon ganz ehrlich allein schon dass du den Server wahrscheinlich ausmachen musst und du keine ordentlichen LEDs hast die dir anzeigen welche Platte kaputt ist ist ziemlicher Müll
Also das ist kein Storage Server den ich mir als Storage Server kaufen würde wenn ich was haben will was 45 Dinger frisst dann muss es nicht so was teures sein
Genau deswegen allein schon weil du nicht richtig reinkommst weil du wahrscheinlich ausschalten musst geht Hotswap nicht richtig also irgendwie ziemlich sinnlos
Ne ich glaube auch mit aktuellen Strompreisen ist es nicht günstiger SSD zu kaufen wenn du mal guckst was SSDs 14TB SSDs kosten wirst du 14TB Platte da kannst du ganz schön lange laufen lassen aber vielleicht wenn so weiter geht ist es so
Ja muss es ja muss es ja sonst funktioniert es ja nicht
Wenn ein Array kaputt geht weil ja wie dieses eine Linus Tech Tips Video wir haben alle unsere Daten verloren oh nein wo ich mir auch schon gedacht habe die sind verdammt ruhig dafür dass sie gerade alle ihre Daten verloren haben
Leute die Dinger kommen ja noch nicht mal in den extra Rahmen rein die kratzen da am Gehäuse gut das ist jetzt nicht schlimm die Platte wird nicht davon kaputt gehen aber Smoothes rein und Raussliding ist damit nicht drinnen
Also von der Konstruktion halte ich nichts ehrlich halte ich nichts sieht aus wie was aus dem 3D Drucker ja ist wahrscheinlich nicht aus dem 3D Drucker ist wahrscheinlich Metall aber das ist das ist das ist keine sagen wir mal Server Storage Server Konstruktion also keine Konstruktion die ich an einem dafür gemachten Storage Server erwarten würde
Das da könnte 3D Druck sein wir gucken mal was das Ding kosten soll
Das da
Wie heißt denn das jetzt Storynator AV15 okay
Eins weiter unten
Ach hier
Okay also was was kostet der Storynator AV15
Das ist durchaus eine Hausnummer ich meine für Enterprise Hardware ist das nichts ja also für sowas hier hast du damals noch nicht mal ein einzelnes IBM Plate bekommen rede nicht vom Plate Center da hast du nicht mal ein einzelnes IBM Plate bekommen aber
Also für ich stelle mir was daheim hin ist es vielleicht ein bisschen teuer
Zumal du halt keinen Hotswap und nichts hast also für den Preis kannst du dir wahrscheinlich relativ gut
Hardware selbst kaufen mit ordentlichen Wechselrahmen wenn du sowas haben willst
Locker ja inklusive HBA und und SSDs
Also ganz im Ernst das überzeugt mich jetzt nicht
Das das ist nur für daheim oder sagen wir mal Small Business vielleicht interessant also mal angenommen du bist jetzt irgendwie ein Fotograf oder so und
Willst du irgendwie besonders viel Speicher willst aber nichts selbst bauen oder möglichst günstig oder irgendjemand beauftragen also keine Ahnung
Ich würde es mir nicht kaufen ganz im Ernst ich würde es mir nicht kaufen ich sehe den Einsatzzweck dafür nicht für mich daheim zu teuer
Und Enterprise der garantiert nicht also tja ist halt echt die Frage wozu man das verwenden sollte
Zumal für mich ist das wichtigste wirklich mit Abstand das wichtigste bei einem Storage Server Hotswapable Front Wechselrahmen
Ob die jetzt mit einem Tray für die Platten kommen oder nicht ist wurscht aber das muss sein und eine LED was kaputt ist welche Platte kaputt ist
Weil wie willst du die kaputte Platte finden dann musst du wieder den gleichen Shit machen wie immer
Du nimmst dir einen Edding und schreibst hinten was drauf und guckst an den Betriebssystem was es gefällt und welche Platte ist es und ziehst die raus
Du Farms Chia wenn du Chia Farms ist das doch absolut unsinnige Investition oder wenn du Chia Farms gehts ja rein
Um sagen wir so möglichst günstig viel Speicherplatz unterzubringen und da sind doch da sind doch beispielsweise externe Saßgehäuse um Längen besser als sowas
Also wenn ich Chia Farmen würde würde ich mir wahrscheinlich ein externes Saßgehäuse kaufen mit was weiß ich wie viele Platten drin
Könnt ihr mir ein externes HDD Case mit Kühlung USB 3 empfehlen? Nö weiß ich nichts
Hey jetzt ist es doch vorne ach ne alter ich kack noob das ist von oben gefilmt
Ich dachte jetzt auf einmal es ist jetzt irgendwie da vorne geklappt aber dann gefilmt einfach oben rein
Guck mal das passt doch nicht immer richtig rein ohne dass es verkannt ist
Also das ist nix das ist das ist wirklich nix wie es quietscht
Platten in einem externen Saßgehäuse brauchen auch nicht mehr als Platten in so einer Kiste drinne
Das Gehäuse an sich braucht ja nicht viel
Alter
Und deswegen sind so Trays für Festplatten auch nicht verkehrt weil die kannst du nicht falschrum reinstecken
Und wie genau passen da jetzt 45 rein?
Das sind jetzt aktuell mal nur 15
Ach vielleicht machen die von diesen Dingern mehr rein oder was?
So muss ein Storage Server aussehen
Wobei das könnte tatsächlich nur in ein Extender Gehäuse sein da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher
So muss ein Storage Server ausgehen
Hotswap Rahmen vorne und LEDs ob defekt oder nicht defekt
Weil das Ding sieht aus wie von 2005 von der Optik her aber so muss ein Storage Server aussehen
Ich mein der hier sieht vielleicht fancierer aus vom Gehäuse her aber rein von der Technik würde ich eher sagen der da unten ist es
Wo der Staubschutz ist wahrscheinlich gar kein du brauchst keinen Staubschutz weil da im Stecker die Festplatten drin stecken
Ja aber du hast schon recht
Da ist auch kein da ist auch kein also gerade für daheim wäre ein Staubfilter sinnvoll hier vorne
Ein Staubfilter weil die Dinger sind ja hauptsinn nicht fürs Rechenzentrum gedacht also hoffe ich mal
Wo du dann eine extra Klimaanlage und Staubfilter drinne hast daheim ist ein Staubfilter eine coole Sache
Aber wie du siehst ich bin aus dem Raum ich habe zwei du hier unten vielleicht wird die Turing Pie da drin gehen aber ich suche einen größeren Rack für meinen Server
Ich habe einen größeren Rack aber ich weiß nicht wie er unten ist also lass mich das in schnell anklicken
Ich habe keine Ahnung aber irgendwie es hat nichts miteinander zu tun aber ich finde die Farbgebung dieses Servers irgendwie erinnert mich das an Keg mit dem Aluhut
Weil hier unten ist es irgendwie so ein bisschen rot und da oben ist es halt Silber quasi Keg Alufärbung
Okay immerhin immerhin schon mal zwei Hot Swappable Netzteile das ist ja schon mal was
Das Mainboard ist ein ganz normales Desktop Ding Oldschool VGA? Oh mein ernsthaft VGA?
Also VGA ist normal im Rechenzentrum sage ich ja auch oft genug aber mittlerweile könnte man für so ein Ding daheim zumindest mal
einen Displayport oder ein HDMI erwarten weil die Leute wollen ja vielleicht mal ein Monitor anschließen und gucken was da so geht
Falls es kaputt ist im Rechenzentrum kein Ding da ist VGA vollkommen normal und die ganzen KVM Switches und sowas die sind auch alle auf VGA noch ausgelegt
Also wenn du die machen zwar USB schon wir hatten im alten Rechenzentrum hatten wir immer noch einen mit PS2 und ihr werdet es nicht glauben
Viele Server haben heute noch PS2 okay die alleraktuellste Generation weniger und da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher weil ich nicht mal auf dem Rechenzentrum war in letzter Zeit
Aber vor kurzem war es noch normal dass Server auch PS2 Anschlüsse hatten und VGA aber trotzdem gerade für so ein Heim bis Small Business Ding wäre vielleicht ein Displayport und HDMI auch nicht verkehrt
Was der Typ macht ich habe auch keine Ahnung der hat 5 Kubernetes Cluster oder so und was auch immer noch alles und Container um andere Container zu verwalten ich check es nicht so genau aber
After hooking up my server and going to the IP address of one of the NICs you see this Houston Houston Command Center ist das in den ist das in den Freenas oder so ne Moment das ist ein Ubuntu es kann kein Freenas sein Moment Freenas Freenas war früher BSD
Ist das immer noch BSD ich hatte irgendwie im Hinterkopf die wollen das auf Debian umziehen aber vielleicht war das auch was anderes
Ja genau
Immer noch BSD
Die haben da bestimmt einfach einen TrueNAS drauf gemacht
Warum will er das Upgraden wenn das quasi fix und fertig so geliefert wird dass es quasi ein
Kein Storage Server in Form von du kannst darauf machen was du willst sondern eher so Storage Richtung Storage Appliance geht dann willst du eigentlich das nicht Upgraden und von Hand drauf rumwursten
By the way Production Update ist bei ihm daheim sein Kubernetes Cluster Updating
Ach Cockpit ist das ja Cockpit kenne ich das ist von von Red Hat glaube ich so ein Management Interface
Webmin ist PainsChamp alter wer verwendet Webmin
Ja es ist es sieht tatsächlich Cockpit ein bisschen wobei Cockpit ist standardmäßig glaube ich das Skin ist glaube ich standardmäßig blau
Oder die Website ist zumindest blau
Das ist nicht blau irgendwie habe ich das im Hinterkopf das ist 1 zu 1 Cockpit ja mit ein bisschen Logo ausgetauscht
Ok die haben quasi 3 Cockpit Plugins gemacht
Na ja da guckt doch keiner drauf
Also dafür hast du normalerweise ein Management Interface wo du dir sowas anguckst
Ist halt die Frage hat das Ding überhaupt ein Management Interface
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Ja ok nice to have
Hat das Ding ein Management Port
Ich hab keinen gesehen ich vermute mal das hat so einen Shared Management Port wie das einige haben
Guck mal wo war das denn jetzt von hinten gezeigt
Doch das hat einen Management Port
Doch doch doch
Oder es hat einfach nur mehrere Netzwerk Ports aber wahrscheinlich hat es einen Management Port
Ok das ist natürlich ganz gut die Anzeige dass du weißt welche Festplatte kaputt ist
Das ist nicht schlecht gemacht
Ja das finde ich ganz gut
Weil normalerweise hast du das Problem du siehst nicht richtig das ist so das das tatsächlich was sinnvolles ja
Dann brauchst du auch keine dann brauchst du auch vorne keine Lämpchen dran
Ok trotzdem keine Ahnung wozu
Ich hab keine Ahnung er weiß ja selbst nicht wozu er es benutzt in den Kommentaren fragt er noch wozu er es benutzen soll
Also ganz ehrlich 100TB allein schon was es für Strom frisst durch pure Ansein hätte ich keinen Bock mehr sowas daheim hinzustellen
Da bin ich mal gespannt ihr wisst ich finde auch nicht alles gut ich bin zwar Linux Fanboy aber ich finde Barbatum auch nicht alles gut
Was man da gesehen hat in einem meiner letzten Videos wo manche Leute wieder komplett eskaliert sind hier Finger weg von Linux
Ich gebe zu vielleicht das Thumbnail ein bisschen Clickbait aber ich denke Video habe ich schon ganz gut begründet
Aber es gab hier schon Leute die haben wieder ein bisschen sind ein bisschen über die Stränge geschlagen
Erzählt ist sowas hier zum Beispiel erzähl keinen Schwachsinn zum Glück ist es kein Windhoff und das Terminal braucht man null möglichst viele Ausrufezeichen ganz wichtig
Er hat es schon ein paar Spezialisten gehabt wieder in den Kommentaren so schauen wir her
Wir können das schon mal überspringen hier geht es eigentlich wirklich los
Ja da bin ich auch erneut drüber über Parts of the Linux Community
Ja da hat er recht deswegen benutze ich auch Arch by the way Wayland ist Crap naja gut Wayland funktioniert aber mir einfach nicht
Also das einzige was garbage ist ist Snap Ubuntu Snap
Snap ist Shit korrekt der Typ hat recht wie auch immer das hier gepostet hat Snap ist Shit so sieht es aus und Netplan ist auch Shit
Ja das stimmt
Ja deswegen ist auch das einzig wahre ganz im Ernst der System Paket Manager ist halt heute nicht mehr so gut unter Arch Linux ist es ja eh schon immer so eine Mischung gewesen aus offiziellen Quellen und User Repos
Aber mittlerweile hast du ja alles NPM Gems PIP plus zusätzlich noch Snap Flatpak im Zweifel kannst du es direkt im Container laufen lassen
Ist halt ist halt ist halt so wie es ist es ist es ist nicht schön das stimmt schon
Ja das ist das Problem das versuchen die ja alle das ist dieses wie das ist wie dieser XKCT Comic und jeder denkt wahrscheinlich er hat es geilste erfunden
Ja man das hast du eines je nach Distribution das hast du nicht alles auf einer
Welches Menü ich habe noch nicht mal ein Menü
Das kannst du nicht miteinander vergleichen
Sieht auf den ersten Blick ähnlich aus Flat und Snap Pak kannst du miteinander vergleichen okay App Image nicht App Image hat einen anderen Hintergrund
App Image ist dafür gedacht um Single File Executables zu machen das hier ist eher so eine Richtung Installer App Store hier geht es hauptsächlich darum Anwendungen zu packagen so dass du sie quasi als für in Windows Sprache als eine Exe ausliefern kannst und sie funktionieren
Wobei die mit App Image auch schon einige Probleme hatten weil sie verwenden zum Beispiel Lipfuse 2 und die hat Ubuntu letztens nicht ausgeliefert und dann geht es wieder nicht ja ist alles Crap deswegen ist tatsächlich Go eines der Programmiersprachen die da riesen Vorteile hat was Deployment angeht ein Go Programm
Das kompilierst du und dann geht es einfach also solange wir nicht von irgendwelchen Abhängigkeiten zu UI Frameworks und gedünsten also wenn die dynamisch irgendwie GTK linken oder so haben das gleiche Problem aber an sich Go Binaries gehen halt einfach
Was ziemlich nice ist muss man sagen
Es funktioniert nicht
Ich schaue an dich Deepin Stop
Das nächste Punkt ist Hardware und ich weiß Hardware Support ist nicht spezifisch
Leute ich bekomme jetzt auf der Arbeit einen Surface Book
Und
Läuft da Linux drauf
Ich habe denen gesagt ich installe Linux drauf und die wollen mir es quasi nackig vorbei bringen und ich darf Linux drauf installieren läuft das da überhaupt gescheit drauf
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt
Wie geht
Na ja
Es funktioniert schon relativ gut
Es ist lange her dass ich auf wegen der Kiste aktuell so bunt umarmen wollte das ging nicht
Ja gut das ist was anderes wenn du dann irgendwelche Spezialdinger unterstützen willst wo die Hersteller ein Scheiß drauf geben dass man sie ordentlich ansteuern kann ja das ist das ist was anderes aber so das normale Zeug Betriebssystem drauf booten Tastatur USB funktioniert Display funktioniert sonst was wenn natürlich dann das Switchen von der Onboard GPU auf eine externe USB 4 GPU Lösung nicht gescheit funktioniert ja das ist was anderes
Das ist was anderes
Ja korrekt das ist das was ich auch in meinem Video gesagt habe
Du hast vieles was erstaunlich gut funktioniert solange es funktioniert und wenn es halt nicht funktioniert hast du da so deine Probleme
Das stimmt ja da hat er recht
Korrekt genau und wenn es nicht wirkt dann ist es entweder erst gar nicht möglich oder nur mit sehr viel Workaround und Hex und Knowledge zu lösen ja das ist so da hat er vollkommen recht
Na ja gut Linux ist noch yet ready würde ich so gar nicht sagen Linux wird in diesem Gebiet höchstwahrscheinlich nie ready sein
Worst als dass nichts funktioniert weil du in diesem Fall die Manufaktur verletzt bist du nicht Linux verletzt
Und es ist das gleiche mit Mac OS oder Windows versuche Mac OS auf irgendeinen genetischen Laptop zu installieren und siehst du wie gut es geht
Oder siehst du wie lange es Valve hat um Windows komplett auf der Steam Deck zu machen
Wenn ein Gerät nicht gebraucht wird mit einem bestimmten OS kann die Erfahrung ziemlich schlecht sein
Und Linux hat kein Recht auf so viele verschiedene Geräte und ich werde auch nicht erwähnen
Na ja er hat schon recht aber dann muss man sich nicht wundern dass es auch keiner benutzt wenn es nicht richtig funktioniert aus seinem Gerät
Oder gerade das was er machen will nicht richtig funktioniert also das komplett das eine zum anderen
Und im Vergleich zu Mac OS ist ja nun mal Linux auch wenn man es mal zu Windows vergleicht gedacht also die meisten Distributionen sind ja so als General Purpose X86 Desktop PC System gedacht
Es ist nicht wie Mac die da drauf ausgelegt sind wir laufen nur auf Mac Hardware nur mit unserer Architektur nur mit unserem Shit drinne und sonst gar nicht
Es ist ja schon in die gleiche Richtung gedacht wie auch das dort wo man Windows verwendet
Nur mit dem Unterschied dass du unter Windows halt deutlich bessere Herstellerunterstützung hast
Nicht zwangsläufig bessere Treiber weil ich könnte mir vorstellen mancher Open Source Treiber die reverse engineered wurden und nicht vom Herstellerkompunkt vielleicht sogar besser
Aber muss ich dann halt nicht wundern wenn die Leute sagen ja Mist was weiß ich meine Bildschirme heller und dunkler Taste nicht richtig funktioniert dann ist es halt für mich nicht benutzbar kann ich verstehen
Naja so big ist das jetzt auch wieder nett
Ja ist es ja auch auf dem Desktop doch ja Moment Moment
Es ist ja nicht und natürlich Leute die in technischen berufen arbeiten und in diesen in ihren berufen das benötigen was Linux gut kann natürlich verwenden die Linux
Trotzdem gibt es davon in der Summe nicht viel
Spielen
Leute die ins Internet gehen und in diese Statistik Erfassung fallen da ist das so und die meisten Seiten die diese Statistik Erfassung machen sind auch eher sagen wir mal eher
Technik Seiten wo eh schon Anteil mäßig mehr Leute draufgehen die Linux verwenden und außerdem ist der User Agent heutzutage gar nicht mehr sonderlich aussagekräftig also
Das ist alles so ein bisschen ich gebe im Prinzip schon recht dass es in der Summe immer noch relativ viele sind aber trotzdem
Das ist eher so ein bisschen ja nebulös die ganzen zahlen da
Also du musst dann erste mal ist das das kann man nicht so rechnen ja sagen wir mal sagen wir mal einfach es gibt 80 Millionen Linux
Linux Desktop Benutzer so und was willst du denn für eine Software anbieten du müsstest irgendeine Software anbieten die dann potenziell auch 80 Millionen Leute interessiert
Weil es kaufen wir eh nur ein Bruchteil davon davon dann wirklich auch deine Software also müsstest irgendwas irgendwas wirklich irgendwas was alle brauchen und was die halt auch
Wo es jetzt noch nicht was Adäquates gibt das ist das ist gar nicht mal Keg WS Service zum Beispiel ja das ist gar nicht mal so einfach weil ansonsten wenn es was bisschen Nischen mäßiges ist sagen wir vielleicht
Irgendwas für
Keine Ahnung
Irgendeine Katz Software oder irgendwas ja irgendwas was nur eh von der Nische noch mal Nische braucht dann dann wird das so nicht funktionieren dann hast du viel zu wenig die das machen und gerade Leute was professionell verwenden die auch viel Geld für die Software ausgeben würden die haben meistens ja schon irgendwas und steigen dann auch nicht um
Also die besten Chancen die ich noch sehe sind tatsächlich die Wellopper Tools und die Wellopper Tools ist eher was Cross Platform mäßig ist was halt auch Linux mit unterstützt
Ja zum Beispiel JetBrains ja ich habe den JetBrains Abo ich benutze Rider für C-Sharp und das läuft auch unter Linux so einfach wie er sich das hier macht ist es glaube ich net da wirklich was zu finden in der Breite wo es noch nichts gibt wo die Leute haben wollen dazu kommt halt noch dabei das Linux User
Ich meine ich weiß das von mir selbst und ich kenne auch noch 3 Linux User sind natürlich da auch besonders wählerisch was das angeht ja wohingegen die NMAC User alles installiert wo Apple drauf steht oder die Windows Oma alles runter lädt und Admin Rechte gibt ist es halt unter Linux so
So nach dem Motto ok ich lese mir jetzt erstmal die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen des Anbieters durch aha ich habe in Abschnitt 3 etwas nicht DSGVO konformes gefunden dann kann ich diese Software sicher nicht verwenden
Also du hast halt Leute oder wo ist denn das Open Source Github Repo für eure Software wie ihr seid nicht Open Source dann schreibe ich euch jetzt erstmal einen riesen Hate Post auf Reddit wie kann das sein dass ihr Linux Software verkauft die nicht Open Source ist und ihr macht jetzt alles schlecht und ich weiß viel besser wie es geht und euer Business ist eh kacke ich hoffe ihr sterbt alle
So solche Comments gibt es dann auf Reddit also rein auf Linux User sich zu verlassen ist glaube ich wirklich ein äußerst schwieriges Unterfangen
Du solltest eher gucken dass du Linux User und das ist das was ja auch schon passiert dass du Linux User bei Tools wo sich das anbietet die Cross Platform sind mitnimmst zum Beispiel bei JetBrains macht es gut JetBrains IDE ist alles Cross Platform zum Beispiel
Ich habe mir ein JetBrains Abo gekauft und ich verwende zum größten Teil JetBrains oder Linux also dass du sowas oder irgendwelche Online Services Spotify was auch immer das Browser Anwendungen Linux ich glaube das ist das was du machen musst eine Anwendung zu entwickeln die explizit auf Linux Desktop Benutzer zugeschnitten ist und dann auch in einem Bereich was quasi alle davon auch potenziell das klappt nicht
Und ganz im Ernst wenn es da was offensichtliches gäbe dann hätte das auch schon irgendjemand gemacht bei mir ziemlich sicher so einfach ist es nicht
Ich glaube die haben das durchaus analysiert und Realize und haben festgestellt es ist einfach nicht so
Okay
Vielleicht sind die auch happy dass einfach mal überhaupt was läuft
Die Frage stellt sich doch gar nicht Leute einfach Arch Linux
Just look at the Grub Problem an Arch
Nein Nein Nein Nein das haben wir letztens gelernt Arch hatte kein Grub Problem nur irgendwelche komischen 3rd Party Arch Linux Verwurstungen hatten Probleme
Er hat eine Veränderung gemacht, die viele Arch-based Distros von Booting verhinderte, die ein paar User in ihre Systeme zu Ch-Route fordern und Grub zu reinstallieren
Nicht etwas, das jeder kann. Schauen wir uns an Glib C
Arch hatte auch das Problem und dann habe ich es falsch verstanden ich dachte Arch hatte nicht das Problem
Ich glaube ich dachte nur irgendwelche Arch-Verwurstungen hatten das Problem
Ach nee okay dann habe ich nichts gesagt tatsächlich
Also was ist? 30.8.
Wie ist es denn jetzt wenn ich jetzt update muss ich dann überhaupt noch was machen oder ist es jetzt gefixt mittlerweile
Also wenn ich jetzt update ist alles gut wahrscheinlich
Hoffentlich mal
Ja gut genau habe ich eh aufgegeben was das angeht
Auch lage Zeit daran das Hardware H264 bzw. Hardware Video Decoding nicht funktioniert hat
Das sollte dadurch schon eine ganze Ecke besser geworden sein, vorausgesetzt man hat die richtige Kombination aus Treibern Hardware und alles Möglichen
es denn dann funktioniert und dann auch nicht bei allen Formaten und auch nicht automatisch auf
YouTube ohne Browser Plugins. Aber wenn man das gemacht hat, sollte es deutlich besser sein,
aber insgesamt ist es wahrscheinlich immer noch hinter Windows zurück. Ne, von 4k Unterstützung
hat er nichts erzählt. Oder meinst du mich? Also ich hab was, ich mein Hardware Video Decoding,
dass du es nicht mit deiner CPU machen musst. Das ist lange Zeit problematisch gewesen unter
Linux und ist es im Prinzip immer noch. Achso der Video, ne der regt sich einfach drüber auf,
dass sein Akku kürzer läuft.
Ich würde sagen einfach nur noch Tempel OS verwenden, dann ist alles gut. Wieso? Sieht doch gut aus.
Wie gesagt, die haben das realist und haben festgestellt, es lohnt sich nicht.
Da hat er recht, da hat er tatsächlich recht. Das habe ich echt, das hat er schön gesagt. Ich
glaube vielen Leuten geht es tatsächlich darum, möglichst als, möglichst Elite rüber zu kommen.
Gerade auf Reddit, deswegen benutze ich ja auch Archlinux. Das hat er aber gut eingebaut.
Und wenn hat er doppelt Sponsor? Alter, der wird es aber wissen. Guck mal hier. Ein Sponsor
und noch ein Sponsor. Doppelt Sponsor. Das ist ja mal hier krass.
Finde ich aber nicht verkehrt. Man muss schauen, wo man bleibt. Als Content Creator. Man muss gucken,
wie es, früher hätte man gesagt, dass der Rubel rollt. Weiß nicht, ob das heutzutage die beste
Sache ist. Man muss halt gucken, dass es läuft. iPhone versus 13 pro versus 12. Lohnt sich der
Wechsel? Die Antwort darauf ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher nein. Ist das Julien Bam? Nee,
oder? Wo kann ich sagen sein, wann macht der Technik Videos? Nee, das sieht immer auf den
ersten Blick ähnlich. Sponsoring Slots in Max FPS Videos. Ja, es ist jetzt so, als könnte ich
nicht. Leute, heute Morgen reingekommen. Ich lese es euch mal vor. Hello NordVPN Advertising.
Oh Mensch, muss man den Browser kleiner machen. Hello NordVPN Advertising. My name is I'm an
agent for NordVPN. At NordVPN we have one goal and that is to make the Internet a more secure
and private place. We are researching for social media influencers who could help to promote NordVPN.
Would you like to find out if you would be interested in promoting NordVPN on YouTube channel?
Okay, mal gucken, was wollen die? Was wollen die haben? Lass mal kurz gucken. Short clip 15
bis 20 Sekunden lang. Showcase is the feature. Oh, das würde ich machen. Also, lustigerweise,
ich erzähle euch das mal. Die vergessen das nämlich immer wieder. Ich wollte mit NordVPN
schon mal was machen und wir waren uns sogar auch einig über was genau und Preis und dann sind die
anscheinend noch mal die Videos auf meinem Channel durchgegangen und haben dieses Video hier gefunden,
was vielleicht ein bisschen abschreckender Titel ist für einen VPN-Anbieter. Unverständlicherweise.
Zumindest haben die dann zu mir gesagt, Max, wir können das Sponsoring nur machen, wenn du
dieses Video löscht. Dann habe ich gesagt, machen wir halt kein Sponsoring. Kannst du einen
guten Clipboard-Manager empfehlen für Windows? Nimm doch einfach den eingebauten. Windows V.
Ich meine, der ist jetzt nicht so feature-rich mit allem, was es so gibt, aber der hat eine Suche
und eine History. Das reicht in der Regel. So Leute, ich leite das mal kurz meinem Managers weiter,
dass der sich da, der kann sich darum kümmern und NordVPN, mit NordVPN was ausmachen.
Dann mache ich demnächst NordVPN-Sponsoring, easy. Ich werde das, Leute, ich werde überhaupt nicht,
ich weiß jetzt schon, ich weiß jetzt schon, wie ich das mache. Ich werde überhaupt nicht irgendwie
großartig erzählen, dass ich das benutze oder sonst wie. Ich mache die übliche Geschichte,
wie das mittlerweile auf YouTube gang und gäbe ist. Ich werde erzählen, NordVPN ist der Premium-VPN-
Anbieter des Jahres 2022. NordVPN erlaubt es euch, das Blablabla zu machen und deswegen
anonyme im Internet zu sein. Jetzt schaut unten in meiner Beschreibung den Link vorbei bei NordVPN.
So, so werde ich das machen. 20 Sekunden easy money. Ich könnte mir einmal vorstellen,
dass wenn sie sich mein Channel genauer angucken, sie wieder nicht wollen,
nachdem sie das festgestellt haben. Kannst du kurz zusammenfassen,
warum VPN Mist ist? VPN ist nicht Mist pauschal. Nur das, wofür das VPN an vielen Stellen beworben
wird, ist halt, kann man halt so nicht halten. Also, die erzählen dir zum Beispiel, dass du mit
einem VPN viel sicherer unterwegs bist, ohne genauer zu definieren, was sicher ist. Du bist
mit einem VPN genauso anfällig für Viren von der Webseite und sonst wie was. Also nur,
weil dein Traffic über den VPN geht, ist es nicht automatisch sicherer. Und nur,
weil dein Traffic über den VPN geht, heißt es auch noch lange nicht, dass keiner was mitlesen
könnte. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Entweder machst du HTTPS, da kann eh keiner was mitlesen,
außer du und der Anbieter. Oder du machst HTTPS oder irgendwas anderes unverschlüsseltes über
VPN, dann kann keiner mitlesen auf der Strecke zwischen dir und dem VPN-Anbieter, aber auf der
Strecke vom VPN-Anbieter zum Zielserver und zurück, selbstverständlich. Also, die Versprechen und die
Sachen, die da teilweise gemacht werden auf der Homepage, trifft schlicht und ergreift nicht zu.
VPNs verwenden kann durchaus sinnvoll sein. Angefangen von, sagen wir mal, irgendwelchen
öffentlichen WLANs, falls das wirklich irgendjemand... Ja, der VPN-Anbieter kann auch mitlesen. Das ist
auch ein Punkt, den ich in meinem Video angesprochen habe. Wie sehr traut man denn seinem VPN-Anbieter?
Die sagen alle, ho, wir haben keine Logs und wir machen das alles hier und so. Warte mal ab,
ist das Sondereinsatzkommando bei denen vor der Tür steht, was sie dann rausgeben und was nicht.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, ihr sollt irgendwelche illegalen Dinger machen, aber viele Leute,
gehe ich mal von aus, haben einen VPN, weil sie da drüber vielleicht, sagen wir mal,
grenzwertig legale Sachen machen wollen. Und dann ist halt die Frage für diese Leute,
wie viel Wert legen die oder wie viel geben die auf die Versprechen der VPN-Anbieter? Und wenn
VPN-Anbieter sagen, sie loggen nix mit, ja, weißt du das? Das sagen das... Es sagt ja auch kein
anderer Anbieter, wir schneiden was mit oder wir speichern mehr als wir dürfen. Das sagen die
ja auch nicht. Machen es trotzdem manchmal. VPN-Anbieter wirklich nix loggen, das weißt du nicht.
Die lassen sich bestimmt nicht, die lassen sich euch bestimmt nicht per SSH bei ihnen sich einloggen.
So. Für sowas ist es tatsächlich sinnvoll, wenn man weiß, wofür man es verwendet und lässt... Also,
wenn man es nicht wegen den komischen Versprechen verwendet von ihnen auf der Homepage, sondern man
weiß, warum man es verwendet. Region-Log, kann man damit umgehen. Wird allerdings auch immer
schwieriger, weil die Streaming-Anbieter mittlerweile, Absender, IP-Rangers und so,
mittlerweile checken, was da von VPN-Anbietern kommt und dann ist so ein bisschen Katz-und-Maus-Spiel,
wer ist schneller? Also, wenn du... Was weiß ich, wenn Leute irgendwelche Torrent-Geschichten
machen wollen oder Filme vom Android-Streaming-Ding gucken wollen über irgendwelche File-Sharing-Dienste
vom Fernseher aus, übers Android-TV. Ja, und wollen definitiv sicher... Also, wollen sicher gehen,
sicherer gehen, da irgendwie nicht erwischt zu werden und Abmahnungs-Sachen zu bekommen. Ja,
klar, dann können die alle einen VPN verwenden. Aber, dass man sich jetzt einredet, man ist rein
durch das Benutzen eines VPNs jetzt irgendwie vor allem sicher, so wie das ja auf den Homepages
angedeutet wird von den VPN-Anbietern, das ist ja ein kompletter Schwachsinn. Also, in der Regel,
die Leute, die VPNs verwenden, sind halt welche, der drüber, sagen wir mal, Videos ziehen wollen,
Newsnet-technisch, Torrent-technisch, wie auch immer, und halt nicht erwischt werden wollen oder eben
Region-Logs umgehen wollen oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja, dafür kann man VPN verwenden,
da macht es zwar nicht legaler, was man da drüber macht, das ist natürlich immer noch nicht erlaubt,
aber die Chancen, dass man erwischt wird, ist halt geringer. Ja, aber ansonsten, ansonsten braucht
man keinen VPN. Und ich brauche eh keinen VPN, weil das meiste, was ich gucke, in den 99%, gucke ich
halt über irgendwelche Streaming-Dienste, sei es Amazon oder irgendwas. Das einzige, wo ich letztens
tatsächlich mal wieder irgendwo was geguckt habe, ist, als es Amazon nicht geschafft hat. Ich habe
die komplette Serie gekauft, bei Amazon, ja, und Amazon hat irgendwie zwei Wochen gebraucht,
die Folge online zu stellen, und dann war noch nicht mal Originalsprache. Und da habe ich mir
gedacht, Amazon wolle mich verarschen, dann habe ich mir das irgendwo rausgesucht und Streaming
technisch angeguckt. Aber was willst du machen? Ich meine, ich war doch keine zwei Wochen nach
Release, bis Amazon ihren Scheiß auf die Reihe kriegt. Selbst dran schuld.
Also Amazon ist da wirklich echt, also was Videos angeht, kommst du dir echt vor wie 2005 oder so.
Anzeige ist raus, jawoll. Ein Regenlog umgehen ist nicht illegal. Das ist erlaubt. Du wirst
vielleicht gebannt, wenn sie dich erwischen, falls der Anbieter es nicht will. Aber Torrentsachen
ziehen darfst du nicht. Habe ich auch nicht gemacht. Torrent ist halt das Problem, dass du
selbst scherst zum Downloaden, also neben Downloaden. Bei Usenet-Sachen sieht es ein
bisschen anders aus, wobei ich halt auch da sagen würde, ich bin jetzt kein Anwalt oder so,
aber Usenet-Angebote sind so offensichtlich schon illegal, dass das jeder erkennen muss.
Ja, bei irgendwelchen Streaming-Seiten, die aussehen wie normale Seiten, dann ist halt
nicht fragwürdig. Aber letztendlich ist ja gar nicht die Frage, ob legal oder illegal,
die Leute, die das über einen VPN machen, die sind sich sehr wohl bewusst, dass es eigentlich
zumindest Grauzone ist, was sie machen, sonst würden sie es natürlich nicht über einen
VPN machen. Was? Also mein Klo zum Beispiel ist nicht zugänglich für alle EU-Bürger.
Oder was? Ich verstehe nicht, was du meinst. Eine Sache, von der ich finde, die tatsächlich
für jeden zugänglich sein sollte, sind das, was öffentlich-rechtliche Sender produzieren.
Also ich finde, Produktionen öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender, die wir alle bezahlen, sollten copyright-frei
für Leute aus Deutschland benutzbar sein. Wir bezahlen den Kram, der Kram wird damit
hergestellt, also kann man danach auch verwerten. Warum nicht? Aber das ist nicht so.
Müssen in der EU nicht alle Dienste verfügbar sein für... Nö. Wenn ein... Wenn jetzt
ein Streaming-Anbieter entscheidet, sein Angebot nicht in Frankreich anzubieten, dann ist das
seine eigene Entscheidung. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber vom Namen her würde ich wahrscheinlich
sagen, ja. So, was gucken wir uns sonst noch an? Gucken wir uns überhaupt noch was an?
Ich muss mal aufs Klo. Ja, wir gucken uns mal an. Wir haben ja wieder nur drei Videos
geschafft, weil ich so viel geschwänzt habe. LUL. HD. W. XD.
Mal eine Off-Topic-Frage. Hast du bei deinen Tasmotor-Geräten das Web-Passwort gesetzt
oder laufen die in einem eigenen Netz und Subnetz? Äh... Nein, hab ich nicht. Ich
hab das Web-Passwort nicht gesetzt. Die stehen bei mir im China-Chinesen-Wilan, wo auch alles
andere IoT-mäßige steht. Ich hab kein Web-Passwort gesetzt. Also, es ist nicht so... Also, man
kommt aus dem normalen WLAN, wenn man die Adresse kennt. Ich überleg grad, kommt man
an Tasmotor-Geräte ran aus dem normalen WLAN? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Nee, da hab ich eine
extra Regel für. Das geht normalerweise nicht. Du kommst vom normalen WLAN nicht ins IoT-WLAN
und kommst vom IoT-WLAN nicht ins normale WLAN. Aber ich komm von meinem internen Netz
ins IoT-WLAN. Und das IoT-WLAN kommt auch an den MQTT-Broker dran. Ja, dir steht es
ja auch, Freidienstleistungen zu erbringen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass du gezwungen bist,
sie zu erbringen. Also, wenn ich jetzt in die Schweiz fahr, kann ich da Schweizer Fernsehen
gucken. Nee, die Schweiz ist doof. Wenn ich jetzt nach Österreich fahr, kann ich da österreichisches
Fernsehen gucken. Das heißt nicht, dass die gezwungen sind, das zu veröffentlichen, sodass
ich in Deutschland österreichisches Fernsehen gucken kann. Also, ich denke nicht, dass man
das da reinreprätieren kann. Gose und Steckdosen sind das Beste für Tasmotor. Richtig, POG
sind die. POG. Allerdings nur die Gose und Dosen, die Strommessen, also Verbrauch messen
können und zwei USB-Steckdosen haben. Das sind die besten hier. Gose und SP. Nein. Ja.
Allerdings nicht für den Preis und nicht, ja doch, für 4-Steck. Und nur wenn flashbar.
Nur wenn flashbar. Wenn nicht mehr flashbar, dann nix. Die sind gut, weil die können Stromverbrauch
messen unter zwei USB-Steckdosen, zwei USB-Stecker und du kannst die Stecker hier oben unabhängig
von den Steckern da unten schalten. Also, für mich ist das in Kombination die beste
geflasht, wohlgemerkt, nur geflasht, die beste Smart Home Steckdose, die man sich
holen kann. Ein einziges Problem ist, sollte es wirklich sehr eng sein, dass man quasi
fast nur den Stecker in die Steckdose kriegt und keinen Platz hat, dann ist das nix, dann
würde ich aber was anderem gucken. Weiß ich, lassen die sich noch flashen? Die lassen
sich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flashen, oder? Hast du eine gute Library für Windows-UI-Automation?
Ne, ich kenne, da kenne ich auch nur Auto-it, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung, was es da sonst
noch gibt. Ja, gut, das ist ja auch das gleiche. Not possible. Fuck. Kein. Wie durchsucht man
noch Kommentare nochmal? Das ist immer so. Ah, alter, die Amazon-Bedienung teilweise
etwas smother. Ja, 2021, das bringt ja nix. 2022. Nicht mehr flashbar. Kein ESP, ach,
guck mal, die neuen haben noch nicht mal ein ESP 8266. 8622, ne, 8266 heißt es ja. Drauf.
Dann hat es keinen Sinn, dann bringt das auf gar keinen Fall kaufen, dann mehr. Muss man
mal gucken. Es gibt noch manche, wie hieß nochmal dieser Shop, der preflashed das Motorgeräte
hat? Das ist tatsächlich eine Option, wobei ich die Geräte an sich dann nicht so geil
finde. Also die Hammer-Steckdosen-Leiste, die hat sich letztens noch flashen lassen.
Guck mal, was denn mit dem da? Da kommt auch oft ganz, das ist doch gerade das, was ich
offen hatte, oder? Ne, das ist was anderes. Ach, das ist die ohne USB. Na, ohne USB ist
Crap, dann lohnt sich das nicht. Der muss schon USB dran sein. Das Motor funktioniert.
Ja, ohne USB ist Müll, man braucht das mit USB. Zum Glück habe ich noch ein paar hier.
Mit USB, MILFRA. Ziemlich blöder Name. Haben die USB? Die haben nur eine USB? Warum gibt
es da schon wieder so viel Zeug? Und die haben eine LED oben, das mag ich nicht. Ich mag
keine, die vorne LEDs haben. LED oben, matt ist gut, aber grüne LED vorne mag ich nicht.
Kann man die flashen? Schauen. Ja, anscheinend, das ist jetzt schon zu lange. Na gut, es ist
schwierig geworden, da was zu finden. Kann man das per das Motor eigentlich ausschalten?
Das kommt drauf an, was für Hardware verbaut ist. Wenn die Möglichkeit besteht, dann hast
du mit das Motor bessere Chancen als mit der offiziellen, aber wahrscheinlich ist die LED
da so dran gelötet, dass du das gar nicht ausschalten kannst. Was du machen kannst,
wenn du gerade dabei bist, manche Geräte muss man ja auch öffnen, um sich an die Pins zu
löten, um das Motor zu flashen, dann kannst du das gleich abmachen. Ja, es gibt manchmal
welche mit Zigbee, aber die das Motor Geräte sind in der Regel das preisgünstigste und
das beste von der Firmware her. Und bei Steckdosen ist ja der Stromverbraucher auch kein Problem.
Steckdosen können ruhig über WLAN gehen. Der hat aber nur drei Stecker. Guck mal, der
hat nur drei Stecker. Das finde ich ein bisschen wenig, ehrlich gesagt. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
an, das sind die USB Steckdosen. Guck mal, die andere Steckdosenleiste, die ich hier
habe, die hat vier Stecker und vier USB. Die ist gut. Ich meine, wenn es sonst nichts
gibt. Okay. Haben wir vielleicht noch mehr Tastmotor, vorinstalliertes, installiertes Zeug.
Hier sieht nicht so aus. Na, egal. Was hast du denn mit den 10G-Kabeln vor? Mit was? Weißt
du, was ich im Warenkorb habe, oder wie? Hier. Das ist alt, das habe ich schon alles.
Was ich damit vorhabe, was anschließen? Das sind Direct-Detached-Kabel, da braucht man
keine Module. Was anschließen habe ich damit vor? Oder hatte ich vorher? Mittlerweile
ist es ja angeschlossen. Ja, wenn du was preflashed haben willst, ist es natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Also das letzte Mal haben wir folgendes geflashed. Das letzte Mal haben wir die hier geflashed
mit Tastmotor. Das hat noch funktioniert, allerdings die, die ich gekauft habe, die lagen
bei mir auch ein halbes Jahr oder so im Schrank, bevor ich die geflashed habe. Ja, vier Dinger,
vier hier. Es ist fraglich, ob das noch geht. Da muss man mal schauen, ob das noch möglich
ist. Hast du ein YouTube-Video, wie man sowas flasht? Nein, aber wir haben im Stream-Archiv
ein paar, wo man das sieht. Ja, also anscheinend ist das noch flashbar. Ist das schon wieder
zehn Monate her? Ne, das da, hier ist es, wo wir das geflashed haben im Stream zusammen.
Guck da oben liegt doch die Steckdosenleiste auch schon. Ja, da wird geflashed. Mehr Kabelsalat,
hier wird geflashed. Das hat funktioniert. Guck und hier haben wir ja auch Tastmotor
drauf jetzt. Ne, das ist blöd, das würde ich nicht machen. Du musst ja immer noch
die offizielle Firmware drauf haben mit China-Chinesen-Zeug. Das kommt bei mir nicht in Frage. Warum
man das andere löten musste? Weil es zwar den richtigen Microcontroller drauf hatte
für Tastmotor, aber zu neue Firmware, um es auf die Air-Flashen zu können, da musstest
du an die Signal-Pins dran zum Flaschen. Das war ein größerer Akt, da habe ich mir
echt ein abgebrochen, das weiß ich noch. Watt, CS, Dankeschön für die Subscription.
bei Gosund an den Support schreiben und nach einigen Teilen wird eine neue Firmware
erstellt. Wirklich? Geht das? Weißt du das aus eigener Erfahrung? Wie sollen das funktionieren?
Wie sollen das funktionieren? Die können ja schlecht remote deine Steckdose updaten
mit der Firmware, sodass du selbst flashen kannst. Oder können die wirklich remote deine
Steckdose updaten? Das wäre für mich ein weiterer Grund, niemals im Leben China-Chinesen-Ungeflashte
China-Chinesen-Dinger an mein Netzwerk zu hängen. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das würde
bei mir überhaupt nicht funktionieren, weil die im IoT-WLAN hängen und das hat kein
hinterher Zugang. Die haben das gar nicht absichtlich unterbunden. Die neuesten Versionen
von dieser Firmware sind einfach nicht mehr anfällig dafür und die verwenden halt neuere
Firmware-Versionen, damit sie eben auch neue App-Versionen nehmen können. Man muss nämlich
wissen, diese ganzen Anbieter, also Gosund baut die ja nicht, das sind ja alles Tuya-Geräte
mit Tuya-Cloud und Tuya-App und sonst was und die werden einfach schlicht und ergreifend
die neueren Versionen von denen verwenden, dass sie neuere Apps verwenden können. Wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal, um diese Flash-Lücke zu patchen. Die nehmen einfach die neueste Version, weil
es die neueste Version ist und die ist halt nicht mehr anfällig für OTA-Flashen. Ich
meine, das OTA-Flashen war eh ziemlich sixhead. Der Raspberry Pi hat einen WLAN aufgemacht
mit dem Namen, wie das WLAN in der China-Chinesen-Fabrik hieß und daraufhin dachten dann die Steckdosen,
aber wir sind in China und verbinden uns mal zu diesem WLAN und lassen uns flashen. Das
ist die Kurzvariante davon. Ist noch bisschen komplizierter.
Ich muss aufs Klo. Vielleicht machen wir nachher. Die Fiat 500e Integration in Home Assistant
fertig. Müssen wir nämlich noch fertig programmieren heute Abend, dass ich den Kram endlich benutzen
kann. Achso. Ich will ja gar nicht, dass sie drauf zugreifen können. Die kommt bei mir
gar nicht ins Etat. Das Pokka, genau. Heißt nicht der aktuelle Tour de France-Gewinner?
So? Fast! Fast! Er heißt fast Pokka. Nee, er ist kein Franzose. Achso, die Tour de France.
Ich glaube, er ist aus Tschechien oder so. Baguette-Tour. Ein richtiger Pokka-Champ, genau. Stimmt.
Wo ist dein Keks hin? Konto kann nicht abgerufen werden, steht bei mir gerade da. Ich glaube,
bei dir ist irgendwas kaputt. Warum geht das hier? Ach, da geht's oder was? Hä? Sind
das zwei? Keine Ahnung. Ich würde sagen, das ist kaputt. Konto kann nicht abgerufen
werden. Twitch-Bun. Bist du noch im zweiten Channel aktiv und spammst da rum? Bist du
noch im zweiten Channel aktiv und spammst da rum? Bist du noch im zweiten Channel aktiv
und spammst da rum? Bist du noch im zweiten Channel aktiv und spammst da rum? Bist du
Das ist einfach einfach ein Channel, der so heißt, oder?
Nee.
Nee, das ist kein Channel, der so heißt.
Das ist irgendwas von Twitch, oder?
Pissow.
Dann hat Twitch, Twitch 5 Head sich gedacht,
wir benennen das mal lieber so, weil es garantiert Bugs gibt,
wenn sich irgendeiner undy fein nennt
oh man
ja leute ich gehe jetzt auf ich muss aufs klo und heute abend machen wir wahrscheinlich weiter
vier atom assistant integration dass das mal funktioniert gibt es null ok das kucke ich noch mal kurz
ok null hat tatsächlich schon mal gestreamt den gibt es letztes jahr
gibt es für die c++ fans gibt es null pointer tatsächlich aber der streamt nicht
alles klar wir sehen uns denn euer maatsgut bis denn zu